Welcome to our second drink of chair model. In this episode, we talk about the Scranton Business Park, five families. We got some fun behind the scenes tidbits from Paul Fowst, who plays Cool Guy Paul. And of course, we discussed Michael's love for the chair model in the office supply magazine. That's one of my favorite plot lines. I know. It's so perfect. I'm going to kick us off with a fan theory that a lot of you wrote in about.
欢迎来到我们的第二期《椅子模特》节目。在这一集中，我们讨论了斯克兰顿商业园的五大家族。我们从饰演“酷哥保罗”的保罗·福斯特那里得到了一些有趣的幕后花絮。当然，我们还讨论了迈克尔对办公用品杂志中那位椅子模特的热爱。那是我就最喜欢的情节线之一。我知道，太完美了。我要先从你们很多人写信提到的一个粉丝理论开始。
Douglas K. and many others said, I always thought the chair model looked like Jan, and that's why Michael was so obsessed with her. And Asma wrote in and said, the chairlady is Jan with black hair. Jenna, what do you think about this theory? Should we look at a side by side? You know, I love a side by side. I know. I have it right here.
道格拉斯·K和其他许多人说，我一直觉得那个椅子模特长得像简，这就是为什么迈克尔对她如此着迷。阿斯玛写信说，那个椅子模特就是留着黑发的简。珍娜，你对这个理论怎么看？我们要不要看一张对比图？你知道，我喜欢对比图。我知道，我这就拿出来。
I kind of, it's the eyes. I see it a little bit. I see it in the eyes. Mm-hmm. Otherwise, I don't see it. If I'm being totally honest, Douglas and asthma, I'm sorry. I see it a little bit. I do.
我有点……是眼睛的原因。我确实看出来了一点。我从眼睛里看出来了。嗯。除此之外，我看不出来。如果我完全诚实地说，道格拉斯和阿斯玛，我很抱歉。我确实看出来了一点。真的。
I can see why Michael, it looks like he has a type. I mean, his type is woman. Truly. Well, we also talked about the gal that Kevin is going to set Michael up with, you know, Wendy, but then Michael calls the phone number that Kevin gave him and it's an actual Wendy's restaurant. I had reached out to Kent Sbornaq to find out who played Wendy. he didn't remember. But guess what? Cori L. wrote in to tell us that the voice of the Wendy's employee was played by Kelly Leskowitz and Corey included a link to Kelly's IMDB page where it is
我能明白为什么迈克尔会这样，他好像有某种偏好。我是说，他的偏好就是女人。真的。好吧，我们还谈到了凯文要给迈克尔介绍的那个女孩，你知道，温迪，但后来迈克尔拨打了凯文给他的电话号码，结果那是一家真正的温迪餐厅。我联系了肯特·斯博纳克，想找出是谁扮演了温迪。他不记得了。但你猜怎么着？科里·L写信告诉我们，温迪员工的声音是由凯莉·莱斯科维茨扮演的，科里还附上了凯莉的IMDb页面链接，上面
listed among her many acting roles. Well, Angela and I thought she crushed this moment, so I think we need to hear it. Okay, Wendy, hot and juicy redhead. We'll give this a try. Wendy's. Hello, Wendy. This is Kevin's friend, Michael. This isn't Wendy. Oh, I'm sorry, could you put her on, please? Dude, this is a Wendy's restaurant.
列出了她众多的演艺角色。好吧，安吉拉和我觉得她在那一刻表现得太棒了，所以我觉得我们需要听听看。好的，温迪，火辣多汁的红发女郎。我们来试试。温迪餐厅。你好，温迪。我是凯文的朋友，迈克尔。这不是温迪。哦，对不起，能让她接电话吗？伙计，这是温迪餐厅。
Okay. Could I just have a frosty and a baked potato, please? You have to come to the restaurant to order food. Well, send somebody to pick it up. Just have it ready. It's ready now. Well, put it aside. Read on, it's ready now.
好吧。我能要一个冰霜奶昔和一个烤土豆吗？你得亲自来餐厅点餐。好吧，派个人去取。准备好就行。现在就准备好了。好吧，先放一边。听着，现在就准备好了。
I love that line read. I loved everything that she did in that moment. I thought it was just so great. Well, Michael also goes on a cringy blind date with Pam's landlady, and some folks wrote in asking us if this scene was a nod to the BBC office. You know, when David Brent attempts to go on a blind date with Susan and the Christmas special Part 2. Oh, I remember it.
我喜欢那句台词的演绎。我喜欢她在那一刻所做的一切。我觉得真是太棒了。好吧，迈克尔还和帕姆的房东进行了一次尴尬的盲约，一些人写信问我们这个场景是否是在向英国版《办公室》致敬。你知道，就是大卫·布伦特在圣诞特辑第二部分试图和苏珊盲约的那次。哦，我记得。
It is also super cringy, and you know what? I think they're right, because both scenes start out so similar. One's at a cafe, one's at like a bar, but they start out very much on the same tone. I'm going to play the first 36 seconds of this scene in the UK version, and then we're going to play the first part of Michael's blind date. Yeah, I spoke to your phone. It seemed quite nice, so a bit of a bit sick, really. Not nerves, excitement, really.
那也超级尴尬，你知道吗？我觉得他们是对的，因为两个场景的开头太相似了。一个在咖啡馆，一个在酒吧，但它们的基调非常一致。我要播放英国版中这个场景的前36秒，然后我们要播放迈克尔盲约的第一部分。是的，我和你通过电话。听起来挺不错的，有点……有点恶心，真的。不是紧张，是兴奋，真的。
Not sexual, you know. She said to be wearing a white chiffon scarf to help me spot her. So, oh, for fuck. David? Huh? Yep, hi. Susan. Yeah, yeah.
不是性方面的，你知道。她说她会戴一条白色雪纺围巾让我认出她。所以，哦，该死。大卫？嗯？是的，嗨。苏珊。是的，是的。
Can I get you a drink? No, okay. Have you got one? You go sit down, I'll get one. Our suspect has straight brown hair. She is wearing blue jeans and a black top. So, behold, our bachelorette, give her a ten for looks, and a three for her ability to describe herself. Hello, my lady.
我能给你买杯喝的吗？不，好吧。你有喝的吗？你去坐下，我去买。我们的嫌疑人留着棕色直发。她穿着蓝色牛仔裤和黑色上衣。那么，瞧，我们的单身女郎，外貌打十分，自我描述能力打三分。你好，女士。
Michael? Uh. Uh. Are you Michael Scott? Scott? So Michael, what? Oh, I'm sorry, I'm supposed to be meeting someone named Michael. Oh, that's not, yeah.
迈克尔？呃。呃。你是迈克尔·斯科特吗？斯科特？所以迈克尔，什么？哦，对不起，我应该见一个叫迈克尔的人。哦，那不是，是的。
Michael? Michael? Large hot chocolate with caramel and shot of peppermint. Okay, yes. I agree. It is. It's, yes. Right?
迈克尔？迈克尔？大杯热巧克力加焦糖和薄荷味。好的，是的。我同意。确实是。是吧？
I think everyone that wrote in is right, because basically they have a description of what this person might be wearing. Yep. They're at a bar or cafe, like looking around, and then the person walks up and they're both like, oh, shit. Yeah. Yeah. Have you ever been on a blind date? Like truly like a blind date? No. I haven't. Have you? No. I was never even like on a setup. I've never even been set up. No, I take that back. I did get set up. I was like, I was invited to like a party. Uh-huh, the sneaky setup. But it was kind of known. Actually, I don't think I did know.
我觉得所有写信的人都说对了，因为基本上他们都有关于这个人可能穿什么的描述。是的。他们在酒吧或咖啡馆里，四处张望，然后那个人走过来，他们俩都觉得，哦，该死。是的。是的。你参加过盲约吗？就是真正意义上的盲约？没有。我没有。你呢？没有。我甚至从来没有被安排过相亲。我从来没被介绍过。不，我收回前言。我确实被安排过。我被邀请去参加一个派对。嗯，那种偷偷摸摸的安排。但大家都心知肚明。其实，我觉得我当时并不知道。
I think once I got there, it became very clear to me that I had been invited as a potential love interest for like their single guy friend at the party because I was also single. This happened to me. It's the sneaky setup. It was my mom and a bunch of the church ladies because there was a new youth pastor. They're trying to make a love connection happen. Yeah. And it was so awkward.
我想一旦我到了那里，我就很清楚自己是被邀请作为派对上他们单身男性朋友的潜在恋爱对象，因为我也是单身。我也遇到过这种情况。这就是偷偷摸摸的安排。是我妈妈和一群教会的女士，因为来了一位新的青年牧师。她们想撮合一段姻缘。是的。太尴尬了。
It became very apparent to me that this whole gathering was so that the two of us might have a spark. Same. These people planned an entire game night. Yeah. We played running charades in hopes that I would have a connection. with this guy. Yeah. But I've never been on like just a one-on-one setup for a blind date.
我非常明显地感觉到，这次聚会就是为了让我们俩擦出火花。我也是。这些人策划了一整晚的游戏。是的。我们玩了猜词游戏，希望我和这个家伙能有火花。是的。但我从来没有参加过那种一对一的盲约。
No, me either. My mom met my dad on a blind date. Oh, that's so romantic. When it goes right, it's a great story. Well, to wrap up, I went to the candy bag alts. You guys know that there were talking heads from everyone as they wrote the names of women on index cards for Michael. You know, Michael was like, oh, yes. You've got to all come up with names of people for me to date.
不，我也没参加过。我妈妈和我爸爸是在盲约中认识的。哦，那太浪漫了。当它成功时，就是一个很棒的故事。好吧，总结一下，我去了糖果袋。你们知道，当每个人在索引卡上为迈克尔写下女性名字时，都有他们的采访片段。你知道，迈克尔当时说，哦，是的。你们都得想出名字让我去约会。
Yeah. So there were a lot of these talking heads that didn't make it in. People had strong reactions about writing these names on index cards. I'm going to read you Toby and Oscar. Okay. Toby, forcing your employees to set you up isn't really a violation of any Dundermifflin rule, mostly because nobody at corporate ever considered that someone would do this. Michael really thinks outside the box.
是的。所以有很多采访片段没有被剪进去。大家对在索引卡上写名字这件事反应很强烈。我要给你们读读托比和奥斯卡的。好的。托比：强迫员工为你安排相亲并不违反邓德·米夫林的任何规定，主要是因为公司里没人想到会有人这么做。迈克尔真的很有创意。
Yeah, there's no rule because who would do that? Who would do that? Here's Oscars. Michael and my sister might hit it off. Oh, Thanksgiving with Michael. You have to think ahead. You've got to plan ahead. All right, everybody.
是的，没有规定，因为谁会那么做呢？谁会那么做？这是奥斯卡的：迈克尔和我姐姐可能会合得来。哦，和迈克尔一起过感恩节。你得未雨绸缪。你得提前计划。好了，各位。
Please enjoy your second drink of chair model. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
请享受你们的第二杯《椅子模特》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。
Hi, everybody. Hello from our closets. Still here. Still in our closets. Still surrounded by Josh's many, many hats. So many baseball hats. So many. Does he have a favorite?
大家好。从我们的衣橱里向大家问好。还在呢。还在我们的衣橱里。周围还是乔什的许多许多帽子。好多棒球帽。太多了。他有最喜欢的一顶吗？
Can we get him on the pod to ask him to give us a breakdown of these hats? Are they significant emotionally in some way? Do they represent a team he loves? I mean, no, I think Josh is all about the fit. And it looks like he loves the Patagonia kind of trucker looking hat. It does with the adjustable band thing, the little plastic snappies. Josh, I hope you are excited that we shared. Listen, there's other things in the closet.
我们能请他上播客，让他给我们讲讲这些帽子吗？它们在情感上有什么重要意义吗？它们代表他喜欢的球队吗？我是说，不，我觉得乔什纯粹是为了搭配。看起来他喜欢巴塔哥尼亚那种卡车司机风格的帽子。确实，带有可调节的带子，那种小塑料扣。乔什，希望你很高兴我们分享了。听着，衣橱里还有别的东西。
Right over my shoulder, I notice all the time that there's the, what's the stuff they spray in their shoes, Jenna? Fabriz. No. All dudes do this. They spray that stuff in their shoes. Odor eaters? Yes, yes. Anyway, oh, now Josh, you're really happy. I've shared with everyone that you spray your shoes.
就在我肩膀后面，我一直注意到有那个，他们喷在鞋子里的东西是什么，珍娜？法布瑞斯（除味喷雾）。不。所有男人都这样。他们把那东西喷在鞋子里。除臭剂？是的，是的。总之，哦，现在乔什，你真的很高兴。我已经告诉大家你喷鞋子了。
Well, because we need to talk about this longer, I am really curious about the very bright red pair of shoes over your shoulder in the shoe cubby. Who's are those? Oh, those are my red converse. Okay, so here's the thing. Yes, this is Josh's closet, but I occupy most of the shoe space. I have lots of shoes. You have overflow that goes into his closet. Yeah, he's real happy about it. Well, guys, it's what you're here for. A breakdown of Angel's Closet. Next week, we'll do my closet. But this week, we are talking about chair model.
好吧，因为我们需要更深入地谈谈这个，我真的很好奇你肩膀后面鞋柜里那双非常鲜红的鞋子。那是谁的？哦，那是我的红色匡威。好吧，事情是这样的。是的，这是乔什的衣橱，但我占用了大部分鞋子空间。我有很多鞋子。你的鞋子溢出来放进他的衣橱里了。是的，他对此很高兴。好吧，伙计们，这就是你们来这里的原因。安吉拉衣橱的剖析。下周，我们将剖析我的衣橱。但本周，我们谈论的是《椅子模特》。
It's so good. Season 4, episode 14, written by B.J. Novak, directed by Jeffrey Blitz. With a duo like that, you know it's going to be good. I love the simple idea that Michael has a thing for the model in a chair catalog. I just love how simple. and perfect that is. Yes. Let me give you a summary. Do it. Michael is unable to pick a new chair for his office after he becomes infatuated with a woman modeling office chairs in a catalog. He decides he's ready to rejoin the dating pool. He's inspired by his love of the chair model. Meanwhile, the Dundermifflin
太棒了。第四季第14集，由B.J.诺瓦克编剧，杰弗里·布里茨导演。有这样的组合，你知道这集一定会很棒。我喜欢迈克尔对椅子目录里的模特有感觉这个简单的想法。我就是喜欢它那种简单而完美的感觉。是的。让我给你们总结一下。来吧。迈克尔在迷恋上目录中一位椅子模特后，无法为他的办公室挑选新椅子。他决定重返约会市场。他受到了对椅子模特的热爱的启发。与此同时，邓德·米夫林的
parking spaces are being used by a construction crew doing work for W.B. Jones. And the the staff of Dunder Mifflin has to park in a satellite lot. Kevin and Andy joined forces to confront the other bosses of the Scranton Business Park to reclaim their places in the main lot. Simple storylines, absolute perfection. Also, absolutely true. Yeah. You know, I had to park in a satellite lot when I had my admin job. If you were an executive, you could park in the parking lot of the building, this high rise in downtown Los Angeles. Yeah. I did not get a parking space. I had to park in a satellite lot that was about a half a mile away, and it wasn't a big deal except for on days that it rained. Well, here's the thing. You know where you rank in a company by where you park.
停车位被一个为W.B.琼斯工作的施工队占用了。邓德·米夫林的员工不得不停在卫星停车场。凯文和安迪联手对抗斯克兰顿商业园的其他老板，以收回他们在主停车场的车位。简单的故事情节，绝对的完美。而且，绝对真实。是的。你知道，我在做行政工作时也得停在卫星停车场。如果你是高管，你可以停在洛杉矶市中心那栋高层建筑的停车场里。是的。我没有停车位。我不得不停在离公司大约半英里远的卫星停车场，除了下雨天，这没什么大不了的。好吧，事情是这样的。你知道你在公司里的地位，就看你停在哪里。
Oh, yeah. Well, Michael has a spot right up front. He's not concerned. Well, later, he's going to try to imagine what it would be like if he didn't have that spot. Mm-hmm. But it takes two employees. Boy, he's angrily confronting him for him to get there. What are our fast facts, Jenna? Fast fact number one. The original title of this episode was Michael Dating. Hmm. But they realized that they would have to release the name of the episode before dinner party had aired.
哦，是的。好吧，迈克尔在前面有一个车位。他不担心。好吧，后来，他会试着想象如果他没有那个车位会是什么样子。嗯。但他需要两个员工，男孩，愤怒地对抗他，他才能意识到这一点。我们的速记事实是什么，珍娜？速记事实第一条。这一集的原始标题是《迈克尔约会》。嗯。但他们意识到，在《晚宴》播出之前，他们必须公布这一集的名称。
Oh, and they didn't want that. They didn't want to ruin the surprise about Jan and Michael's breakup, right? Yes. So they changed the name of the episode to parking. But then they felt, well, while it's a big part of the episode, it's not the main storyline of the episode. So they eventually settled on chair model, which I personally love. I mean, when you see that, aren't you intrigued? I'm so intrigued.
哦，他们不想那样。他们不想破坏简和迈克尔分手的惊喜，对吧？是的。所以他们把这一集的名字改成了《停车》。但后来他们觉得，虽然这是这一集的重要部分，但它不是主要故事情节。所以他们最终定名为《椅子模特》，我个人很喜欢。我是说，当你看到这个标题时，难道你不感兴趣吗？我太感兴趣了。
What is this episode going to be about? Chair model. I'm more intrigued than parking. I'll say that. They picked the right one. All right. Fast fact number two, I think we need to do a little breakdown of the Scranton Business Park five families. I mean, it's like Goodfellas.
这一集会讲什么？椅子模特。我比对《停车》更感兴趣。我得这么说。他们选对了标题。好了。速记事实第二条，我觉得我们需要对斯克兰顿商业园的五大家族做一个小小的剖析。我是说，这就像《好家伙》。
It is. All right, here are the bosses of the five families, Michael Scott, of course. Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. Then there is W.B. Jones from W.B. Jones Heeding and Air. He was played by Barry Sigismundi. Bill Kress of Cress, Tool and Die, who was played by Terrence B. Sur. And finally, Paul Faust of Disaster Kits Limited, who was played by Paul Faust.
确实。好了，这是五大家族的老板：迈克尔·斯科特，当然。鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷公司。然后是来自W.B.琼斯供暖与空调公司的W.B.琼斯。他由巴里·西吉斯蒙迪饰演。克雷斯工具与模具公司的比尔·克雷斯，由特伦斯·B·瑟饰演。最后是灾难工具包有限公司的保罗·福斯特，由保罗·福斯特本人饰演。
This is an amazing story, and it all starts when an actual man named Paul Faust came to visit the set of the office. Yes, so I have known Paul Faust for years. We used to be related by marriage, and I reached out to him, and he's just such a hoot, and he sent in all of these fantastic audio clips about his day on set. They are amazing, and in this first one, he explains exactly how. he got the role on the show. Sam, you got to play this clip. Hey, office ladies and office fans. This is Paul Faust, a cool guy, Paul. I want to tell you how I got a part of the show. So I was out in L.A. business and decided to visit
这是一个了不起的故事，这一切始于一个叫保罗·福斯特的真实男人来参观《办公室》的片场。是的，所以我认识保罗·福斯特很多年了。我们曾经是姻亲，我联系了他，他真是个风趣的人，他发来了所有关于他在片场一天的精彩音频片段。它们太棒了，在第一个片段中，他准确地解释了他是如何得到这个角色的。萨姆，你得播放这个片段。嘿，办公室女士和办公室粉丝们。我是保罗·福斯特，酷哥保罗。我想告诉你们我是怎么得到这个角色的。当时我在洛杉矶出差，决定参观
the set because my cousins are part of the office. And when I was out there, I met the writers, and I kind of told him one of my companies and what I did, which was a company that sells his answer kits. And Greg, it said, this is my cousin. He's a little nuts. Tell him what you do. I told them about the company. And when I walked out of the room, unbeknownst to me, B.J. Novak said, that guy's got to be a character on the show. So he wrote a part based on me. And the day before they shopped the scene, they hadn't found an actor to play the part. So I got a call asking me if I wanted to audition to play the part.
片场，因为我的表亲是《办公室》的一员。当我在那里时，我遇到了编剧，我向他介绍了我的公司和我的工作，那是一家销售灾难工具包的公司。格雷格说，这是我的表亲。他有点疯。告诉他你是做什么的。我告诉了他们关于公司的事。当我走出房间时，我不知道，B.J.诺瓦克说，那个家伙必须成为剧中的一个角色。所以他根据我写了一个角色。在他们拍摄那个场景的前一天，他们还没有找到演员来演这个角色。所以我接到一个电话，问我是否想试镜演这个角色。
And long story short, I got the part, got to fly out and be part of the awesome show and play myself. So that's how I got to be on the show. It's really a story only could happen in Hollywood. I mean, that's bonkers. I know. He's literally playing himself. But what's bonkers to me about it was that they did hold auditions. They held auditions for this role.
长话短说，我得到了这个角色，飞过去参与了这个很棒的节目，并扮演我自己。这就是我如何参与这个节目的。这真是一个只有在好莱坞才会发生的故事。我是说，这太疯狂了。我知道。他实际上是在扮演他自己。但对我来说，疯狂的是他们确实进行了试镜。他们为这个角色进行了试镜。
And the night before, they just had not found someone who could play Paul Faust. So they're like, how about Paul Faust? Paul really sells disaster kits. That's real. That is his company. Oh, yeah. And, Angela, he talked about that in this next clip. I think one of the most unique things about me being in the office was that I actually played myself.
而在前一天晚上，他们就是没有找到能扮演保罗·福斯特的人。所以他们说，保罗·福斯特怎么样？保罗真的卖灾难工具包。那是真的。那是他的公司。哦，是的。而且，安吉拉，他在下一个片段中谈到了这一点。我认为我参与《办公室》最独特的事情之一就是我实际上扮演了我自己。
When I went out to L.A. and I was visiting and I went to the set, I talked about one of the businesses I run, which is a company called 1-800-Prepair.com, where we actually sell disaster kits and prepare of his kits. So I talked about it, and that's what DJ had picked up on. And so he wrote a part called About Cool Guy Paul, the owner of Disaster Kids, limited and yes, I still own that company. We still sell disaster kids. So I think I'm one of the few people who played himself on TV with his real name in a real business that he runs, which was kind of cool. So we asked Paul, how did he prepare, you know, to have these scenes? He's not an actor. He's not used to learning lines or where to sit, you know, how to navigate a set and all that
当我去洛杉矶参观片场时，我谈到了我经营的一家企业，那是一家名为1-800-Prepair.com的公司，我们实际上在那里销售灾难工具包和准备工具包。所以我谈到了它，这就是B.J.注意到的。所以他写了一个叫“酷哥保罗”的角色，灾难工具包有限公司的老板，是的，我仍然拥有那家公司。我们仍然销售灾难工具包。所以我认为我是少数几个在电视上用真实姓名和自己经营的真实企业扮演自己的人之一，这很酷。所以我们问保罗，他是如何准备这些场景的？他不是演员。他不习惯背台词或站在哪里，你知道，如何驾驭片场之类的
kind of stuff. And here's what he had to say. So I got this part. let's say on a Thursday and I had we were shooting Friday morning so I had about a good 10 hours to learn my five or six lines so I'm studying studying on the plane I'm reading them I didn't sleep I studied them so we go there and this whole experience happens and you're nervous and there's a lot of people around and I had 10 hours to learn a bunch of lines so I was able to do it and we knocked it out and and I got it done and I was like great I finished and then all of a sudden somebody came in and they threw these new scripts down. They said, okay, here's the altered and ending.
事情。这是他要说的。所以我得到了这个角色，假设是在周四，我们周五早上就要拍摄，所以我大约有10个小时来学习我的五六句台词，所以我一直在飞机上学习，我读着它们，我没睡觉，我学习它们，所以我们去了那里，整个经历发生了，你很紧张，周围有很多人，我有10个小时来学习一堆台词，所以我能够做到，我们完成了它，我做到了，我当时想太棒了，我完成了，然后突然有人进来，他们扔下了这些新剧本。他们说，好吧，这是修改后的结局。
Let's take a five minute break, learn our lines and come back at you. And I'm like, wait, wait, what a minute? Five minutes? What? I had 10 hours to learn my lines. Five minutes, I'm not learning new lines. So I raced out the hallway, had to study, learn all the lines, learn when I came in and whatever. A lot of doing it, knocking it out, getting it done right.
我们休息五分钟，学习台词，然后回来。我当时想，等等，等等，什么？五分钟？什么？我有10个小时来学习台词。五分钟，我学不会新台词。所以我冲出走廊，不得不学习，学习所有台词，学习我什么时候进来等等。做了很多次，完成了它，做对了。
And again, life experience with amazing people who were just so supportive. that I was glad that I was able to be a tiny part of this amazing family. Well, Angela, I found an interview with Paul and he said that he landed in L.A. at 1.30 in the morning. The airline lost his luggage, so he had no luggage. He got to his hotel and went to sleep about 3.15 in the morning, and he had to be up at 5 a.m. for work. So after all of that, I'm kind of amazed. I would have been loopy. I wouldn't have been able to learn new lines.
再一次，与那些非常支持我的人一起的生活经历。我很高兴我能成为这个了不起的家庭的一小部分。好吧，安吉拉，我找到了保罗的一次采访，他说他凌晨1点30分到达洛杉矶。航空公司弄丢了他的行李，所以他没有行李。他到达酒店，凌晨3点15分左右睡觉，他必须在早上5点起床工作。所以经历了这一切，我感到很惊讶。我会变得神志不清的。我不可能学会新台词。
No. And I think of Paul just like he's had no sleep. He's probably in the same underwear because they lost his bag. And he, you know, and now he's like, he thought he reached the finish line. And then they hand him this whole new task. Well, Paul sent a few more clips about his experience. Just being on set, they're so delightful. We're going to sprinkle those in throughout the episode. All right. Fast fact number three, Angela. I'm titling this, am I the inspiration? for this episode? I'm sorry, what? Were you a chair model? No. But in season one of the show, I wanted a new chair at reception.
不。而且我想到保罗就像他没睡觉一样。他可能穿着同样的内衣，因为他们弄丢了他的包。而且他，你知道，现在他就像，他以为他到达了终点线。然后他们给了他这个全新的任务。好吧，保罗又发了一些关于他经历的片段。只是在片场，它们太令人愉快了。我们会在这一集中穿插这些片段。好了。速记事实第三条，安吉拉。我给它起名为：我是这一集的灵感来源吗？对不起，什么？你是椅子模特吗？没有。但在第一季中，我想要接待处有一把新椅子。
And I had to lobby for it. So I'm sure I'm not the inspiration for this episode. But in season one, they gave me a chair at reception without arms. It was an armless chair. Mm-hmm. And I really, really wanted a chair with arms. and so I attempted to try to sort of move the chairs or find a chair maybe that hadn't been claimed or used. It wasn't working.
我不得不为此游说。所以我肯定我不是这一集的灵感来源。但在第一季中，他们给了我一把没有扶手的接待椅。那是一把无扶手的椅子。嗯。我真的，真的想要一把有扶手的椅子。所以我试图移动椅子，或者找一把可能没被认领或使用的椅子。没用。
And big shout out to our set dresser, Steve Rothstein, because he is one of the guys who headed up the team that picked out all our furniture on the office. And he got me a chair with arms. Oh, lady. And I was so excited. Well, I have a chair story for you. I've been holding on to this. I'm going to go ahead and tell you now, the chair I'm sitting in right now, ready? I'm going to pan down. Do you see this chair? I do. It's a blue chair with mesh. Do you recognize it?
向我们的片场布置师史蒂夫·罗斯坦大声致敬，因为他是负责挑选《办公室》所有家具的团队负责人之一。他给了我一把有扶手的椅子。哦，女士。我太兴奋了。好吧，我有一个关于椅子的故事要告诉你。我一直留着这个。我现在就要告诉你，我现在坐的这把椅子，准备好了吗？我要向下平移。你看到这把椅子了吗？我看到了。这是一把蓝色的网眼椅。你认得它吗？
I don't recognize it, but it has no arms. Phil Shea gave me this chair. It was a leftover chair from work bus. Oh my gosh, you've been sitting in a work bus chair this whole time for a year in my closet. it. I have been sitting in my work bus chair and I was going to save it for work bus, but we're having all this chair talk. I couldn't hold it in anymore. Well, I just have to say this is why our show is so great because getting a chair is a very relatable big deal moment when you are in an office job or any job, your chair, you sit in it all day and they created this amazing, wonderful storyline out of it. Yes. And thank you, Phil Shea, because. I had gotten a desk, you know, I had in the corner of my guest room a little desk where I would sit and do work.
我不认得，但它没有扶手。菲尔·谢给了我这把椅子。这是《工作巴士》剩下的一把椅子。天哪，你这一整年来一直坐在《工作巴士》的椅子上，在我的衣橱里。我一直坐在我的《工作巴士》椅子上，我本来想把它留到《工作巴士》那一集，但我们一直在谈论椅子。我再也憋不住了。好吧，我不得不说这就是为什么我们的节目这么棒，因为当你从事办公室工作或任何工作时，得到一把椅子是一个非常容易产生共鸣的大事，你的椅子，你整天坐在上面，他们从中创造了这个了不起的、美妙的故事情节。是的。谢谢菲尔·谢，因为。我买了一张桌子，你知道，我在客房的角落里有一张小桌子，我会在那里坐着工作。
And I didn't have a proper desk chair. I was using one of the kitchen chairs. And I was sort of talking about it on set. And Phil Shea was like, Angie, I have some extra chairs from work bus. Do you want one? I was like, yes. This is making me happy. I know. We all have a chair story. And I have been sitting in it for a year with you and haven't told you because I was going to try to work it in a work bus. But there you go. Let's take a break. And when we get back, We'll get into it. All right. What's up, guys? I'm Candace Dillard Bassett, and you may know me from my time
我没有合适的办公椅。我用的是厨房椅子之一。我在片场谈论过这件事。菲尔·谢说，安吉，我有一些《工作巴士》多余的椅子。你想要一把吗？我说，是的。这让我很高兴。我知道。我们都有一个关于椅子的故事。我一直和你坐在一起一年了，没告诉你，因为我想试着把它放进《工作巴士》里。但就是这样。我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会深入探讨。好了。大家好，我是坎迪斯·迪拉德·巴塞特，你们可能从我在
on The Real Housewives of Potomac or as a part of the latest cast of the traders. And I'm Michael Arsinoe, author of the New York Times bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. On our podcast, Undomesticated, we don't just say the quiet parents out loud for putting it all on the kitchen table and inviting you into the chaos.
《波托马克娇妻》中的时间或者作为《叛徒》最新演员阵容的一部分认识我。我是迈克尔·阿西诺，《纽约时报》畅销书《我无法和耶稣约会》的作者。在我们的播客《非驯化》中，我们不仅仅是把心里话大声说出来，我们把一切都摆在厨房桌子上，邀请你们进入混乱。
If you're ready for bold takes, real talk, and a little fun, come join us. Listen to and follow Undomesticated and Odyssey Podcast, available wherever you get your podcasts. We are back. We open on a gym and Pam talking head. They are standing outside of the Dundermifflin office, and they are explaining that due to some renovations in the building,
如果你准备好迎接大胆的观点、真实的谈话和一点乐趣，快来加入我们。收听并关注《非驯化》和奥德赛播客，在你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。我们回来了。我们以吉姆和帕姆的采访片段开场。他们站在邓德·米夫林办公室外面，解释说由于大楼里的一些翻修，
all of their parking spots are being taken up, and they have to park in a satellite lot and walk to work. They're being really positive about it, though. Yeah, they saw a junkyard dog eating, you know, some of a chicken. Yeah, eating the bones of a rotisserie chicken, And Angela, which was based on a real story. It was. There was a junkyard next to our real office building.
他们所有的停车位都被占用了，他们不得不停在卫星停车场，然后步行上班。不过他们对此非常积极。是的，他们看到一只垃圾场狗在吃，你知道，一些鸡肉。是的，在吃烤鸡的骨头，而且安吉拉，这是基于一个真实的故事。确实。我们真正的办公楼旁边有一个垃圾场。
And there was a junkyard dog who they would throw like old rotisserie chicken bones to. We've talked about this junkyard in the dog. We got very invested in this dog's life that lived over there. We did. And it made it into an episode. So then we have Oscar and Andy who are less positive. and then there's Kevin who is just downright angry. Kevin is going to have a breakdown over the satellite parking lot.
有一只垃圾场狗，他们会扔给它一些旧烤鸡骨头。我们谈论过这个垃圾场和这只狗。我们对住在那里的这只狗的生活非常投入。我们确实投入了。它被写进了一集里。然后我们有奥斯卡和安迪，他们就不那么积极了。还有凯文，他简直是愤怒。凯文要因为卫星停车场崩溃了。
Yeah. Well, Andy says he's so bummed because he lost a penny out of his penny loafers. Yeah. Jenna, I don't understand penny loafers, so I looked him up. Oh. You could have asked me, I wore penny loafers all through high school as part of my school uniform. Okay, well, why did you put a penny in your penny loafer? I don't know, because there was a slot there for.
是的。好吧，安迪说他很沮丧，因为他从他的便士乐福鞋里丢了一枚便士。是的。珍娜，我不明白便士乐福鞋，所以我查了一下。哦。你本可以问我的，我整个高中都穿便士乐福鞋，作为校服的一部分。好吧，那你为什么要往便士乐福鞋里放一枚便士？我不知道，因为那里有一个插槽。
for it. Okay, well, I'll tell you. I'll tell you why. Oh, my God. Well, you have put me in my place. I clearly don't know about penny loafers. You told me I could have asked you. Well, you're not answering my question. Why a penny in your loafers? So, according to the internet's, back in the 1930s, the pay phone in the phone booth cost two cents. The new loafer design allowed just enough space for a penny in each shoe, equaling the cost of an emergency phone call. Thus, the penny and the loafer were united. But only men could make emergency phone calls.
放它。好吧，我告诉你。我告诉你为什么。哦，天哪。好吧，你让我无话可说了。我显然不懂便士乐福鞋。你告诉我我本可以问你的。好吧，你没回答我的问题。为什么乐福鞋里要放便士？所以，根据互联网的说法，早在20世纪30年代，电话亭里的公用电话需要两美分。新的乐福鞋设计在每只鞋里留出了刚好够放一枚便士的空间，等于紧急电话的费用。因此，便士和乐福鞋结合在一起了。但只有男人才能打紧急电话。
If you were a woman, so sorry. You don't even get a pocket to put your pennies in. Good luck, lady. You're just going to die on the street. But for the men, we have pockets. You can hide money in your shoes. where else can we make life easy for you, gentlemen? That took a turn, but point taken.
如果你是女人，很抱歉。你甚至没有口袋可以放便士。祝你好运，女士。你只能死在街头。但对于男人，我们有口袋。你可以把钱藏在鞋子里。还有哪里我们可以让你们男士的生活变得轻松？这话题转得有点快，但重点我收到了。
So now the episode starts, and Jenna, it would have started with a deleted scene with Michael checking out of Shrewp farms. What? Yeah. Oh, because he's been staying with Dwight? Yes, so there was an alternate beginning where Michael is leaving the farm and he's like, it's moving day. you know, I've been here about a month. I let Jan have the condo, and I'm moving out of Shrewp Farms. And as he's leaving, Dwight goes hold up and hands him a bill.
所以现在这一集开始了，珍娜，它本应该以一个删除的场景开始，迈克尔从施鲁特农场搬出来。什么？是的。哦，因为他一直和德怀特住在一起？是的，有一个替代的开头，迈克尔离开农场，他说，今天是搬家日。你知道，我在这里住了一个月了。我让简留下了公寓，我正从施鲁特农场搬出去。当他离开时，德怀特说等等，并递给他一张账单。
And Michael's like, wait, you were charging me this whole time? And Dwight was like, yeah. And then they have this funny back and forth about it. Oh, my gosh. My mind is blown by the backstory that Michael lived with Dwight for a month. And it does sort of show why maybe now he's looking at the chair model like he is, because he's a month past his breakup and I don't know, maybe he's ready for something new. Yeah. Oh, can we see this deleted scene somewhere? Yes, it's on the DVDs.
迈克尔说，等等，你一直都在向我收费？德怀特说，是的。然后他们就此进行了一番有趣的来回。哦，天哪。迈克尔和德怀特住了一个月这个背景故事让我大吃一惊。这确实说明了为什么他现在看着椅子模特，因为他分手已经一个月了，我不知道，也许他准备好迎接新事物了。是的。哦，我们能在哪里看到这个删除的场景吗？是的，在DVD上。
Amazing. So the scene they went with is this one in his office. He's looking through the catalog and really just gazing at this late. lady in this chair. Well, we had some fan mail about it. Carly D. Jenna A. Mariah K. and Charlotte S. all wrote in to ask who played the chair model in the picture. The chair model was played by April Eden. She would go on to play Trish, aka Miss Pawnee, in two episodes of Parks and Recreation. Well, I have a little background catch. At a minute, nine seconds, there's a wonderful shot of the chair model, but the magazine is sitting on top of some message slips.
太棒了。所以他们最终采用的场景是他在办公室里的那个。他正在翻阅目录，真的只是盯着这个女士看。好吧，我们收到了一些关于它的粉丝邮件。卡莉·D、珍娜·A、玛丽亚·K和夏洛特·S都写信问照片里的椅子模特是谁扮演的。椅子模特由艾普尔·伊登扮演。她后来在《公园与游憩》的两集中扮演了翠西，也就是波尼小姐。好吧，我有一个小背景发现。在1分09秒，有一个椅子模特的精彩镜头，但杂志放在一些留言条上面。
Oh. And I zoomed in on the message slip. The message that was written down said, Andrea Ufer or Uder guys, I don't know, I couldn't make it out. From Dunder-Lewisville called and asked Michael to please call as soon as he returns. And the number was 307-55-4438. So I called it. Well, that's a fake number.
哦。我放大了留言条。上面写着，安德里亚·尤弗或尤德，伙计们，我不知道，我看不出来。来自邓德-路易斯维尔的人打电话，请迈克尔回来后尽快回电。号码是307-55-4438。所以我打了。好吧，那是假号码。
Well, yeah, it rang fast-busy, but I wasn't sure, so I called it. No, you know that thing where in movies, they always start phone numbers with 555 because nobody has that as a prefix. Jenna, I know that, but we've had a phone number and it ended up being a sex hotline. So I decided to do my due diligence. It is a phony baloney number, but the area code 307 is a Wyoming area code, but there is no Louisville in Wyoming. There you have it. Boom. Everything you needed to know about this message slip next to the catalog.
好吧，是的，它响了忙音，但我不敢确定，所以我打了。不，你知道电影里那种事，他们总是用555开头电话号码，因为没人有那个前缀。珍娜，我知道，但我们曾经有一个电话号码，结果是一个色情热线。所以我决定尽职调查。这是一个虚假的号码，但区号307是怀俄明州的区号，但怀俄明州没有路易斯维尔。就是这样。砰。关于目录旁边的这张留言条，你需要知道的一切都在这里。
Angela, I admire you. I do. I really love that detail. Pam just needs Michael to pick a chair so that she can get his chair. But he is now obsessed with the chair model and Pam is very sad. But then Michael has a talking head where he says, he really likes being single, because he can start off each day with a sense of possibility. And this was my favorite part when this talking head takes a turn. He says, and each day becomes
安吉拉，我很佩服你。我确实佩服。我真的很喜欢那个细节。帕姆只是需要迈克尔选一把椅子，这样她就能得到他的椅子。但他现在迷上了椅子模特，帕姆很伤心。但后来迈克尔有一个采访片段，他说，他真的很喜欢单身，因为他可以以一种可能性的感觉开始每一天。这是我最喜欢的部分，当这个采访片段发生转折时。他说，每一天都变得
more desperate and desperate situations yield the quickest results, which is kind of true. It is true. There was an alt-talking head here that was pretty amazing. Jenna, you know the nursery rhyme where it's like, Pam and Jim sitting in a tree, K-I-S-S-I-N-G, you know that one? Yes. So he's sort of used this nursery rhyme as a template for how to find your perfect match. And Sam, can you play it? Love, marriage, baby carriage. Those have been my goals ever since I heard that song.
更加绝望，而绝望的情况会产生最快的结果，这在某种程度上是真的。确实是真的。这里有一个替代的采访片段，非常棒。珍娜，你知道那个童谣，就像，帕姆和吉姆坐在树上，K-I-S-S-I-N-G，你知道那个吗？是的。所以他把这个童谣当作寻找完美伴侣的模板。萨姆，你能播放吗？爱，婚姻，婴儿车。自从我听到那首歌以来，这些就是我的目标。
Jan and I had love. We did not have marriage. We did have a baby carriage, which I got her for bringing groceries home after she got a DUI. It's just so messed up. And I have to say, Jenna, in this scene with you when he says, remember after my dinner party when I said that I was swearing off women, the way you said, I definitely remember your dinner party was so good. You just crushed it.
简和我有了爱。我们没有婚姻。我们确实有了一辆婴儿车，那是我在她酒驾后带杂货回家时给她买的。这太乱了。我不得不说，珍娜，在这个场景中，当他说，记得在我晚宴后我说过我要戒掉女人吗，你说“我绝对记得你的晚宴”的方式太棒了。你表现得太好了。
I love doing that scene. with Steve. I remembered when I was watching it how much we were laughing. It was just so fun. That was a good memory. It's a very subtle, like, reminder, too, to the audience what just came before this. Yeah. Okay. Well, now, Jenna, we have a creed talking head that is phenomenal. It is phenomenal. He says, when Pam gets Michael's old chair, he gets Pam's old chair, which will bring him to two chairs, only one more to go. Why does he need so many chairs? You're not the only person who's wondering.
我喜欢和史蒂夫一起演那个场景。我记得看的时候我们笑得有多开心。那是一个美好的回忆。这也是一个非常微妙的提醒，提醒观众刚才发生了什么。是的。好吧，现在，珍娜，我们有一个克里德的采访片段，非常惊人。确实惊人。他说，当帕姆得到迈克尔的旧椅子时，他得到了帕姆的旧椅子，这将使他有两把椅子，只差一把了。他为什么需要这么多椅子？你不是唯一一个感到好奇的人。
We got a lot of mail about it. So I texted Creed. Oh, no. And he had a lot of answers for why he needed three chairs and I'm going to share them all. Wait, wait. Is this sort of like Creed, the actor giving Creed the character backstory? Yes.
我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。所以我给克里德发了短信。哦，不。他对于为什么需要三把椅子有很多答案，我要把它们都分享出来。等等，等等。这是克里德这个演员给克里德这个角色背景故事吗？是的。
Oh, I love it. All right. Option number one. He was growing weed in the ceiling. It was the same place where Angela threw her cat. Now, he had access through a crawl space outside, but he needed to get in there at night by his desk. So after finally getting his three chairs and climbing into the ceiling, they collapsed one night and he was stranded in the ceiling. He wants you to know that's a whole thing that could
哦，我喜欢。好了。选项一。他在天花板上种大麻。那是安吉拉扔猫的同一个地方。现在，他可以通过外面的爬行空间进入，但他需要在晚上在办公桌旁进入那里。所以在终于得到三把椅子并爬进天花板后，它们有一天晚上倒塌了，他被困在天花板里。他想让你知道那是一整件事，可能会
have happened. Creed, what the hell are you talking about? You're going to stack three office chairs? I think all three of them had wheels. Yeah. Well, here's option number two. He said Crete stole many things from the office and he needed the extra chairs for a set because he was selling it to a competitive paper company. That, I believe. Yes. I believe Crete had many side hustles. Well, here's his final answer.
发生。克里德，你在说什么鬼话？你要堆叠三把办公椅？我觉得三把都有轮子。是的。好吧，这是选项二。他说克里德从办公室偷了很多东西，他需要额外的椅子作为一套，因为他把它卖给了一家竞争对手的造纸公司。那个，我相信。是的。我相信克里德有很多副业。好吧，这是他最后的答案。
After perfecting his cartwheel, he wanted to use the three chairs as part of an obstacle course to really challenge himself. Well, that could have been very true. Oh, Creed, you are so fun. Thank you for humoring us time and time again. Well, Michael tells everyone in the bullpen, get out your catalogs, open them to page 85, and take a look at the woman in the catalog. Yeah, use that as a template for who you're going to set me up with. Jenna, this was an announcement. He came out of his office to address his employees.
在完善了他的侧手翻后，他想把这三把椅子作为障碍训练场的一部分，来真正挑战自己。好吧，那可能是真的。哦，克里德，你太有趣了。谢谢你一次又一次地迁就我们。好吧，迈克尔告诉休息室里的每个人，拿出你们的目录，翻到第85页，看看目录里的那个女人。是的，把它当作模板，看看你们要给我介绍谁。珍娜，这是一个公告。他走出办公室向员工讲话。
Could you imagine working with a boss that made a huge announcement about how you should go about setting him up? No, later, he says if you don't provide him a name, by the end of the hour, you're going to be fired. We'll get there. But it's crazy. So now, here's what I noticed. We all do get out these catalogs and we start opening up to page 85. And I remember these catalogs, Angela. Do you remember them?
你能想象和一个老板一起工作，他发布了一个关于你应该如何给他安排相亲的巨大公告吗？不，后来，他说如果你在一小时内不给他提供一个名字，你就会被解雇。我们会讲到那里的。但这太疯狂了。所以现在，这是我注意到的。我们都拿出了这些目录，开始翻到第85页。我记得这些目录，安吉拉。你记得吗？
Yes. So we got mail about this, too. Mariah, Charlotte, and Christina all wanted to know. Did the props department have to make an entire. hire magazine just for these scenes with the catalog. No. So what they did was they had like an actual, I don't remember what it was, Angela, do you?
是的。所以我们也收到了关于这个的邮件。玛丽亚、夏洛特和克里斯蒂娜都想知道。道具部门是否必须为这些目录场景制作整本杂志。没有。所以他们做的是，他们有像实际的，我不记得是什么了，安吉拉，你记得吗？
I think it was Staples or Office Depot or something. And they glued a new cover on it. Yes. So it was like a Dundermifflin cover. Yeah. And then on the inside on page 85, they glued this two pages so that when we opened it up, we could show those two pages. But the rest of it was an actual.
我觉得是史泰博或办公仓库之类的。他们粘了一个新封面上去。是的。所以它就像一个邓德·米夫林的封面。是的。然后在第85页的内页，他们粘了这两页，这样当我们打开它时，我们就能展示那两页。但其余部分是一本实际的
office catalog. That's right. And they just had to print basically the cover and then the two insert pages that we would all turn to. Right. Jenna, you might notice there's not a lot of reaction shots of me in this because my belly was so big. I'm peak preggers here. That is why I'm not anyone that walked in, you know, like from the satellite parking lot. Mm-hmm. So Jenna, I don't know if you remember, but this week on our set, Chris Hastings, our NBC set photographer was there. And he took a picture of me at my desk. I'm completely out of character and I'm pointing at my belly. Look, Jenna, here it is. Oh my God, you're huge. I know. Anyway, I'll put that in stories, but yeah, it was getting really hard to hide my belly. Well, there were enough shots of you,
办公目录。没错。他们只需要打印封面，然后打印我们都会翻到的两页插页。对。珍娜，你可能会注意到这里面没有很多我的反应镜头，因为我的肚子太大了。我这里是怀孕高峰期。这就是为什么我不是任何走进来的人，你知道，比如从卫星停车场走进来的人。嗯。所以珍娜，我不知道你是否记得，但本周在我们的片场，克里斯·黑斯廷斯，我们的NBC片场摄影师在那里。他拍了一张我在办公桌前的照片。我完全脱离了角色，指着我的肚子。看，珍娜，在这里。哦，天哪，你太大了。我知道。总之，我会把它放在故事里，但是的，隐藏我的肚子变得越来越难了。好吧，有足够的你的镜头，
Angela and I noticed that they were all very close up. They're like shoulders and up, but it's enough for me to notice that you were wearing a blouse with tiny keys on it. Little, like, skeleton keys. What was it? Lady, look. Look at this picture. It's not a blouse. It's a freaking dress. It was a whole dress of it. It was a turtleneck dress. I mean, it looked like a moo-moo. It was very comfortable. But we were starting to struggle with what could fit me over my belly and look like business attire of someone who was not pregnant. Yeah. I have a question for you. What is it? At three minutes, 35 seconds, you'll notice that Kevin and Michael are sitting on the sofa by front reception.
安吉拉和我注意到它们都是非常近的特写。它们就像肩膀以上，但足以让我注意到你穿了一件上面有小钥匙的衬衫。小的，像骷髅钥匙。那是什么？女士，看。看这张照片。这不是衬衫。这是一件该死的连衣裙。这是一整件连衣裙。这是一件高领连衣裙。我是说，它看起来像一件宽松长袍。它非常舒服。但我们开始纠结什么能适合我的肚子，看起来像一个没有怀孕的人的商务装。是的。我有一个问题要问你。是什么？在3分35秒，你会注意到凯文和迈克尔坐在前台旁边的沙发上。
Michael's wanting Kevin to set him up. He's asking him about Stacey. Do you know why they're sitting on the sofa and why Michael isn't an accounting talking to Kevin? Well, I know that Kevin's feet are in a foot bath. Is that why, though? Yes, Jenna, there's a whole deleted scene where you're trying to answer the phone, but Kevin's footbath, it's so loud. It sounds like a ginormous hot tub, but it's a little foot bath.
迈克尔想让凯文帮他牵线搭桥。他在问凯文关于斯泰西的事。你知道他们为什么坐在沙发上，为什么迈克尔不是在会计部而是和凯文说话吗？嗯，我知道凯文的脚在泡脚盆里。但这真的是原因吗？是的，珍娜，有一整段被删减的戏，你当时正试图接电话，但凯文的泡脚盆声音太大了。听起来像个巨大的热水浴缸，但其实只是个小泡脚盆。
So for the majority of this episode, Kevin is sitting there next to front reception. Yes, he is soaking his feet in his footbath that he bought himself for the Christmas party episode, that very first episode. And it's such a wonderful callback. But since they cut that scene at reception, you can't even really see it. I tried to even find a time code where you could see the footbath and you can't. You can't. You can see just like Kevin's pants are hiked up. You're like, why are they hiked up?
所以在这集的大部分时间里，凯文都坐在前台旁边。没错，他正在泡脚，用的就是他在圣诞派对那一集——也就是第一集——里给自己买的那个泡脚盆。这是一个非常精彩的呼应。但因为他们剪掉了前台的那场戏，你甚至都看不出来。我试着找过能看到泡脚盆的时间码，但根本找不到。你只能看到凯文的裤子卷起来了。你会想，为什么要卷起来呢？
Yeah. Why am I seeing Kevin's bare ankles? But it's because they're resting in a footbath, and that's in the deleted scenes. Well, now Michael's going to walk around the office. He's going to try to make pleas to various people in the office to see if they have any single friends that they can set him up with, which leads to a very funny runner with Phyllis about her friend Sandy. Phyllis is so good in this scene. So good.
是啊。为什么我能看到凯文光着的脚踝？那是因为它们正泡在泡脚盆里，而那段戏被删了。好了，现在迈克尔要绕着办公室走一圈了。他要试着向办公室里的各个人求助，看看他们有没有单身的朋友可以介绍给他，这引出了菲利斯关于她朋友桑迪的一段非常有趣的插曲。菲利斯在这场戏里表现得太棒了。太棒了。
And the way Steve fires off his questions about Sandy. I mean, Phyllis says, look, she's gorgeous with a feisty personality. And Michael's like, so wait, jolly or sassy? Right. And Phyllis is like, no. And he's like, well, what does she do for a living? And Phyllis is like, she's a professional softball player. And Michael's like, mm, catch her or infield?
还有史蒂夫抛出关于桑迪的问题的方式。我是说，菲利斯说，看，她很漂亮，性格活泼。迈克尔就说，等等，是快乐还是泼辣？对。菲利斯说，不。他又问，那她是做什么工作的？菲利斯说，她是职业垒球运动员。迈克尔就说，嗯，是接球手还是内野手？
And she's like, I don't know. Oh, and then he asks her if she could fit in a rowboat in a standard size robot. And Phyllis gets so angry with him. She's like, fine, no, Michael. No, she can't fit in a rowboat. It's really amazing writing. Michael really loses it now, Angela, and he gives this impassioned speech
她说，我不知道。哦，然后他问她能不能坐进划艇里，那种标准尺寸的划艇。菲利斯对他非常生气。她说，行了，不能，迈克尔。不能，她坐不进划艇。这剧本写得真是太绝了。迈克尔现在真的崩溃了，安吉拉，他发表了一段充满激情的演讲，
where he says he wants to play ball with his kids before he's too old. But first, he needs to get laid, and that means he needs to be in love. Oh, that kind of made me love Michael for saying that. He just wants the picket fence and the kids. kids in the two-car garage and he just Michael is one of these people and I and anyone out there that's had children you know how you have one of your kids who just wants a family yes and Michael was that
他说他想在自己太老之前和孩子们一起打球。但首先，他得先有性生活，这意味着他得坠入爱河。哦，迈克尔说出这话让我有点爱上他了。他只是想要那种有栅栏的房子和孩子。孩子和双车位车库，他只是……迈克尔就是那种人，而且我，任何有孩子的人都知道，你总会有一个孩子，他就是想要一个家庭，是的，迈克尔从小就是那个孩子，
kid since he was a little boy all he wanted was a family I mean if you and not to be a downer but I don't think Michael had a great family experience as a child and he's still longing for it as an adult. Of course. That's like part of his whole driving force. Yeah. It's to find family, whether it be at work or with a partner, he wants family. Yes. Well, this is now, Angela, where Michael says, everybody, I want you to give me the name of someone that he can go on a date with within the hour or they're fired. And Dwight is going to hand out index cards. That he's already written prompts for. Did you see that? Yeah, he's ready. He's ready. Well, listen, let's take a break, and when we come back, we will find out how this goes.
他从小到大想要的就只是一个家庭。我是说，如果你——不是要扫兴，但我不觉得迈克尔小时候有过很好的家庭体验，他成年后依然渴望着。当然。那是他整个驱动力的一部分。是的。就是寻找家庭，无论是在工作中还是与伴侣在一起，他都想要家庭。是的。好了，安吉拉，现在迈克尔说，所有人，我要你们在一小时内给我一个他可以去约会的人的名字，否则你们就被解雇了。德怀特要分发索引卡。他已经写好了提示词。你看到了吗？是的，他准备好了。他准备好了。好吧，听着，我们休息一下，回来后，我们会看看进展如何。
Guess what? Not well. Should, maybe, but shan't. That's right. Well, we're back. We're in Michael's office. Andy and Kevin are really making a passionate plea to Michael to please do something about these parking spots that the construction guys are blocking.
你猜怎么着？不太好。应该，也许，但不会。没错。好了，我们回来了。我们在迈克尔的办公室。安迪和凯文正在向迈克尔发出热切的请求，请他对施工人员堵住停车位的事采取行动。
Michael says, you know what? He's gotten assigned parking spots, so not really affecting him. And there is a couplet of dialogue, Jenna, that just cracked me up, seven minutes, four seconds. Michael says, wish I could, but I can't. Well, can, but won't. Should, maybe shorn. And Kevin's like, Michael, please. And then Michael says, what part of short, don't you understand, Kevin?
迈克尔说，你知道吗？他有指定的停车位，所以对他没什么影响。珍娜，有一对台词让我笑喷了，在7分04秒。迈克尔说，希望我能，但我不能。嗯，能，但不会。应该，也许，不会。凯文说，迈克尔，拜托。然后迈克尔说，不会的哪一部分你不明白，凯文？
What part of short? Don't you understand? They're on their own. He's not going to help them. No. But he does give them permission to fix the problem themselves. Yeah. Right?
哪一部分不会？你不明白吗？他们得靠自己。他不会帮他们的。不。但他确实允许他们自己解决这个问题。是的。对吧？
Mm-hmm. He thinks this will be a good thing for them to figure this out. Right. An exercise. Meanwhile, in the break room, I don't even know what title to give this, everyone is sitting trying to come up with a name to put on their card for Michael. We had a fan question from Stephanie, Emily, Laura, and Anne. When giving Michael names of single women he should ask out, Jim writes down Pam's mom.
嗯哼。他认为这对他们来说是一件好事，让他们自己想办法。对。一种锻炼。与此同时，在休息室里，我甚至不知道该给这起个什么标题，每个人都坐着试图想出一个名字写在卡片上给迈克尔。我们收到了来自斯蒂芬妮、艾米丽、劳拉和安的粉丝提问。当给迈克尔推荐他应该约会的单身女性名字时，吉姆写下了帕姆的妈妈。
I know. Right? Was this an intentional foreshadowing or just a coincidence? Well, guys, spoiler alert. In future seasons, Michael is going to date Pam's mom. It was a very controversial storyline. We'll get to it. I think this was the first time the writers had ever even thought of this idea.
我知道。对吧？这是故意的伏笔还是纯属巧合？好吧，伙计们，剧透预警。在未来的几季里，迈克尔会和帕姆的妈妈约会。那是一个非常有争议的情节。我们会讲到的。我觉得这是编剧们第一次想到这个点子。
And it was just a funny joke in the moment, but I have to believe that it stayed in their brain. It planted a seed. Well, there's a deleted scene between Michael and Kelly where Michael's like, Kelly, who are you going to set me up with? And she's like, well, I have a friend who's 23. And he's like, yeah. And she's like, oh, you know, I actually have the perfect group to set you up with. My friend's parents who've gotten divorced. And Michael's like, ugh.
当时这只是个有趣的笑话，但我不得不相信它留在了他们的脑海里。它埋下了一颗种子。嗯，迈克尔和凯莉之间有一段被删减的戏，迈克尔说，凯莉，你要给我介绍谁？她说，嗯，我有个朋友23岁。他说，是啊。她说，哦，你知道，我其实有个完美的人选介绍给你。我朋友的父母，他们离婚了。迈克尔说，呃。
And he walks off disgusted. So there is sort of this running joke in this episode that didn't fully make it in that like, Kelly is going to set Michael up with this whole older group of people. Right. The Diversay. I guess I'll say the writers at this time didn't know yet that they were going to write that storyline, but I think this was the beginning of something. It's the group mind, lady. There it is.
然后他厌恶地走开了。所以这一集里确实有一个没完全播出的梗，就是凯莉要给迈克尔介绍一群年纪大的人。对。迪弗赛。我想说当时的编剧还不知道他们会写那个情节，但我认为这是某件事的开始。这是集体思维，女士。就是这样。
In action. I love that Michael calls Wendy. It's so funny. Do you know who the voice of Wendy was? We got a lot of mail about it. and I wrote to Kent Zabornak. And he did not remember who we cast, but one of the finalists for the role was Lindsay Broad,
在行动中。我喜欢迈克尔给温迪打电话。太搞笑了。你知道温迪的声音是谁配的吗？我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。我写信问了肯特·扎博纳克。他不记得我们选了谁，但该角色的最终候选人之一是琳赛·布罗德，
who ends up playing an arc on the show. Yeah. Now, I don't think she got the role. I really listened to the voice, and I think it was someone else. So I don't have the answer. But I thought it was very interesting that Lindsay had auditioned for just this voice role.
她后来在剧中扮演了一个角色。是的。现在，我不认为她得到了那个角色。我仔细听了那个声音，我觉得是别人。所以我没有答案。但我认为琳赛试镜这个配音角色非常有趣。
Right. Well, you know who's on the case. Who's always on the case? Dwight. Dwight, he's on the case. He's going to find Michael, the chair model. Yeah. And he says, I will find her and I will bring her to you.
对。好吧，你知道谁在负责这事。谁总是负责这事？德怀特。德怀特，他在负责。他要帮迈克尔找到那个椅子模特。是的。他说，我会找到她，我会把她带到你面前。
And as God is my witness, she shall bear your fruit. This is such good writing, in my opinion, that we set up that Dwight is going to go on this quest. And the quest literally lasts one scene. Like, I think the expectation in writing is that we're now going to watch Dwight go on a search for the chair model. But then he sums it all up in one talking head. Yeah, he basically only had to make two phone calls. So the furniture company put him in touch with the advertising agency, who put him in touch with the photographer, who put him in touch with the modeling agency. And the modeling agency told him that she died in a car accident.
上帝作证，她会为你生儿育女。在我看来，这剧本写得太好了，我们设定了德怀特要去完成这个任务。而这个任务实际上只持续了一个场景。就像，我认为写作中的预期是我们现在要看德怀特去寻找椅子模特。但他用一个谈话头就把这一切总结了。是的，他基本上只需要打两个电话。家具公司让他联系了广告代理商，广告代理商让他联系了摄影师，摄影师让他联系了模特经纪公司。模特经纪公司告诉他，她在车祸中去世了。
Case closed. Case closed. Investigation over. And by the way, he's super proud of his investigation, and it's not really landing on him that this is horrible news. Michael takes the news really hard. He has to sit down in Dwight's chair. Yeah. And Jim says, Michael, you didn't even know her.
结案。结案。调查结束。顺便说一句，他对自己调查的结果非常自豪，他并没有意识到这是一个可怕的消息。迈克尔听到这个消息非常难过。他不得不坐在德怀特的椅子上。是的。吉姆说，迈克尔，你甚至都不认识她。
Gasp. Even Pam shakes her head at Jim. I know. Like, Jim. Not now. Michael's like, try not to be so hurtful, Jim. Dwight's like, how dare you? And one of my favorite lines of this whole episode is coming up.
倒吸一口凉气。连帕姆都对吉姆摇了摇头。我知道。就像，吉姆。现在不行。迈克尔说，尽量别那么伤人，吉姆。德怀特说，你怎么敢？这一集里我最喜欢的台词之一就要来了。
What is it? Pam says, okay, Michael, you know what? I might have someone for you. And Michael says, oh, really? What's her name? Burger King? Oh, yeah, that made me laugh out loud too. It made me laugh so hard.
是什么？帕姆说，好吧，迈克尔，你知道吗？我可能有人选给你。迈克尔说，哦，真的吗？她叫什么名字？汉堡王？哦，是的，那也让我大笑出声。我笑得太厉害了。
Pam, for whatever reason, decides to give Michael the phone number of her landlady. Margaret. Mm-hmm. She says she's really nice and I think you might get along. I mean, Michael's jazzed. He's excited. He starts brushing his teeth in the kitchen sink. Why can't he do that in the men's room?
帕姆不知为何决定给迈克尔她房东的电话号码。玛格丽特。嗯哼。她说她人很好，我想你们可能会合得来。我是说，迈克尔很兴奋。他很激动。他开始在厨房水槽里刷牙。他为什么不能在男厕所刷？
Well, don't worry, Angela. He's not going to spit it out. He swallows it. Did you notice that? Yes, so disgusting. Also, electric toothbrush. Also, remember when we were wondering in local ad? Does he have a toothbrush in the office?
嗯，别担心，安吉拉。他不会吐出来的。他咽下去了。你注意到了吗？是的，太恶心了。还有，电动牙刷。还有，记得我们在《本地广告》里好奇的时候吗？他办公室里有牙刷吗？
He does. So now the five families are going to be assembled. Andy and Kevin are doing it. Kevin has a talking head where he breaks down the five families, how they rarely ever meet. Yeah. And they have this great footage of each member of the five families. It's pretty amazing. I have two little fun facts from this.
他有。所以现在五个家族要集合了。安迪和凯文正在做这件事。凯文有一个谈话头，他分析了五个家族，他们几乎从不见面。是的。他们有五个家族每个成员的精彩镜头。太神奇了。我对此有两个有趣的小事实。
Okay. So now when they show W.B. Jones, they kind of show a clip of what looks like a commercial that he's in where he's selling his air conditioners, right? Right. There's a 1-800 number in that commercial on the screen. Did you call it? I didn't need to call it because it's the exact same number that was on the flyer in women's appreciation, which we know is a sex hotline.
好的。所以现在当他们展示W.B.琼斯时，他们播放了一段看起来像是他出演的广告片段，他在卖空调，对吧？对。那个广告屏幕上有一个1-800的号码。你打了吗？我不需要打，因为这和《女性鉴赏》里传单上的号码一模一样，我们知道那是色情热线。
Why do we keep recycling this number? I think we must have bought this number because after this episode came out, they put an outgoing message for WB. Jones. So if you called it, you got that message. Yeah, we must have owned it. for a bit, and we clearly don't own it anymore. We really don't. Well, the other fun fact I have about this little montage is that at 10 minutes, 55 seconds,
为什么我们一直循环使用这个号码？我想我们一定是买下了这个号码，因为这一集播出后，他们为W.B.琼斯设置了一个外呼留言。所以如果你打了，你会听到那个留言。是的，我们一定拥有过它一段时间，显然我们现在不再拥有了。我们真的没有。好吧，关于这个小蒙太奇我还有另一个有趣的事实，在10分55秒，
we see a photo of cool guy Paul sitting on a motorcycle. And there's a very interesting story here. Sam, will you play this clip from Paul? Hey, so a quick story about that motorcycle picture, because a lot of people ask me, is that your motorcycle? And no, it's actually, we were shooting the scenes. And we were supposed to shoot somewhere on some guy's house in the back deck, overlooking the ocean, but it got late in the day,
我们看到酷哥保罗坐在摩托车上的照片。这里有一个非常有趣的故事。萨姆，你能播放保罗的这段录音吗？嘿，关于那张摩托车照片的一个小故事，因为很多人问我，那是你的摩托车吗？不，其实是，我们当时正在拍戏。我们本应该在某个人的房子后甲板上拍摄，俯瞰大海，但天色已晚，
and they didn't want to move the whole crew and the cameras and the lighting and that all that stuff. So right behind the lot where they shoot all the scenes where the office is, is a residential neighborhood. So we went through the fence, and it was some guy's house, and we just set up on the front lawn. I believe it was the motorcycle of one of the camera guys. He happens to ride motorcycle. So he brought his motorcycle around.
他们不想移动整个剧组、摄像机、灯光和所有那些东西。所以就在拍摄办公室所有场景的场地后面，是一个住宅区。所以我们穿过栅栏，那是某个人的房子，我们就在前草坪上布置了。我相信那是其中一个摄像师的摩托车。他正好骑摩托车。所以他把摩托车骑了过来。
I sat on it. We took a bunch of pictures. And that just became the shot associated with cool guy Paul. And it saved having to move everybody to another location and spend hours doing it. So people always ask me, hey, you motorcycle. How did you get the motorcycle? But nope, it was just a quick shot of one of the crew members' motorcycles. Well, Jenna, I reached out to Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup on the show because he rode a Harley, right?
我坐在上面。我们拍了很多照片。那张照片就成了酷哥保罗的标志性镜头。这省去了把所有人搬到另一个地点并花上几个小时的时间。所以人们总是问我，嘿，你的摩托车。你是怎么弄到摩托车的？但不是，那只是其中一个剧组成员摩托车的快照。好吧，珍娜，我联系了肯尼斯·保罗，他在剧中负责我的化妆，因为他骑哈雷，对吧？
To set. Every day to work. And I sent him the picture and I said, Kenneth Paul, is this your motorcycle? And he said, no, Angela, that's not a Harley. It's not mine. So we don't know whose motorcycle it was. But I think that was Tom Milby's yard. Oh, for sure. When I heard Paul's clip and he said we went to some guy's yard through a fence, Tom Melby was our, I guess, general maintenance guy on the show. He was always fixing things when we went on vacations. He was the person who watered the plants. And he lived right behind the set in a house. I loved the idea that cool guy Paul was originally going to be filmed in a big mansion with the ocean behind him.
去片场。每天上班。我把照片发给他，我说，肯尼斯·保罗，这是你的摩托车吗？他说，不，安吉拉，那不是哈雷。不是我的。所以我们不知道那是谁的摩托车。但我认为那是汤姆·米尔比的院子。哦，肯定的。当我听到保罗的录音，他说我们穿过栅栏去了某个人的院子，汤姆·米尔比是我们剧组的，我想是总务人员。我们去度假时他总是修理东西。他是那个浇花的人。他住在片场后面的房子里。我喜欢酷哥保罗最初要在豪宅里拍摄，背后是大海的想法。
It definitely tracks, right? Yeah. But then they had to scramble and they're like, what else is cool? Ooh, a motorcycle. And I kind of love the motorcycle better, actually. actually. I do too. So Jenna, at 11 minutes 30 seconds, it is time for Michael to go on his date. He's at the coffee shop. He's a little early, so he's going to go ahead and get a cup of coffee. Oh, here's his order. Large hot chocolate with caramel and a shot of peppermint. He's going to pay for it with his
这绝对说得通，对吧？是的。但后来他们不得不手忙脚乱，他们说，还有什么酷的？哦，摩托车。其实我更喜欢摩托车。我也喜欢。所以珍娜，在11分30秒，迈克尔该去约会了。他在咖啡店。他有点早，所以他打算先去买杯咖啡。哦，这是他的订单。大杯热巧克力加焦糖和一小杯薄荷。他要用他的
did you notice bejeweled wallet? No. Yeah. What? It's really subtle. But if you freeze at 11, minutes, 26 seconds. Michael is paying for his coffee. Yeah. And his wallet has an outline of little bedazzled fuchsia gems. I am so curious why. Did Jan get bored and bedazzle everything in their whole condo one day? Perhaps. I looked at it so closely. There's no name on it. It's just an outline. I need to see that. Fascinating. Well, he's looking around and he's trying to figure out where's his date. He's wearing a rose on his lapel, right? Because that's how you'll know it's him. Could you imagine if Michael was in The Bachelor, that reality show? So crazy. That would be so good.
你注意到那个镶满珠宝的钱包了吗？没有。是的。什么？真的很隐蔽。但如果你在11分26秒暂停。迈克尔正在付咖啡钱。是的，他的钱包上有一圈闪闪发光的紫红色宝石。我很好奇为什么。是简有一天无聊，把他们整个公寓里的东西都镶上了水钻吗？也许吧。我仔细看了看。上面没有名字。只是一个轮廓。我得看看那个。太迷人了。好吧，他四处张望，试图弄清楚他的约会对象在哪里。他在翻领上戴了一朵玫瑰，对吧？因为那样你就会知道是他。你能想象如果迈克尔参加《单身汉》那个真人秀节目会怎样吗？太疯狂了。那会很棒。
I was thinking the other day, what would I be like on The Bachelor? Oh, God, you wouldn't do it. You'd say, oh, right, all these women have to kiss the same guy. F you, patriarchy. You wouldn't do it. But then I was sort of like daydreaming about me getting out of the limo in my joggers and a hoodie. And just keeping it super real. I was like, dude, I'm getting out of the limo how you're going to see me most of the time after we have two kids.
我前几天还在想，如果我参加《单身汉》会是什么样？哦，天哪，你才不会去。你会说，哦，对，所有这些女人都得亲同一个男人。去你的父权制。你才不会去。但后来我有点做白日梦，想象我穿着慢跑裤和连帽衫从豪华轿车里走出来。只是保持超级真实。我说，伙计，我从豪华轿车里走出来的方式，就是我们有了两个孩子后你大部分时间看到我的样子。
And if you love me now, you're going to love me then. And I think we should start this way. That'd be my pitch. You literally said that with like a snarl in your lip. You're like, this is... I did. It's badass. It's a badass way to start a date.
如果你现在爱我，你那时也会爱我。我觉得我们应该这样开始。这就是我的推销词。你刚才说这话时嘴唇还带着一丝冷笑。你说，这是……我确实说了。这很酷。这是一种很酷的约会开始方式。
If you're getting out of a limo on my first date, you've already lost me. If you want to dial up the doucheery, show up in your limo. Well, Michael sees a woman. It's such a funny line. He says, I'm looking for a woman in blue jeans and a black top with brown hair. And he goes, there she is. And the camera swings to a blonde, a tall blonde wearing a skirt, like a floral skirt with a top, clearly not the description he was given.
如果你在我的第一次约会上从豪华轿车里走出来，你已经失去我了。如果你想增加那种混蛋感，就坐你的豪华轿车来吧。好吧，迈克尔看到了一个女人。这句台词太搞笑了。他说，我在找一个穿蓝色牛仔裤、黑色上衣、棕色头发的女人。然后他说，她在那儿。摄像机转向了一个金发女郎，一个穿着裙子的高个金发女郎，就像一条花裙子配上上衣，显然不是他得到的描述。
But he says, there she is. I give her a 10 for looks and a three for describing herself. Oh, he's so charmed. Okay, obviously the woman in the dress is not his date, since she's dressed nothing as described. But then Pam's landlady walks in Margaret wearing jeans in a black top, and Michael gets one look at her. He's clearly disappointed and he tries to get out of it. Oh, it's so cringy. And she's really cute and like nice. Like what is wrong with Michael? Michael has such a bad picker. Yes. Well, Pam's landlady was played by Brooke Dillman. She is an improv comedy actress.
但他却说，她在那儿。我给她的外表打10分，给她的自我描述打3分。哦，他被迷住了。好吧，显然穿裙子的女人不是他的约会对象，因为她的穿着和描述完全不符。但随后帕姆的房东玛格丽特走了进来，穿着牛仔裤和黑色上衣，迈克尔看了一眼。他显然很失望，并试图摆脱它。哦，太尴尬了。而且她真的很可爱，人也很好。迈克尔到底怎么了？迈克尔的眼光太差了。是的。好吧，帕姆的房东是由布鲁克·迪尔曼扮演的。她是一位即兴喜剧演员。
She starred in this sketch comedy show called Blue Collar TV. And by the way, she has voiced several characters on Bob's Burger. She's amazing. She's just got the chops. Brick is hilarious. I have just known her through improv circles over the years, and she's so funny. And, you know, I know her role as Margaret was supposed to be understated. And I just wish you guys could see the comedy chop she has. I know you see it in her timing of the scene and all of that. But she is really, really funny. You know, a lot of times it takes a great comedic performer to play restraint. Yeah, to have the patience to play the restraint. Yes, and to not try to overload the scene with their own bits.
她主演过一个叫《蓝领电视》的素描喜剧节目。顺便说一句，她为《鲍勃的汉堡》中的几个角色配过音。她太棒了。她很有天赋。布鲁克太搞笑了。多年来我一直通过即兴表演圈认识她，她太有趣了。而且，你知道，我知道她扮演玛格丽特的角色应该是低调的。我真希望你们能看到她拥有的喜剧天赋。我知道你们在场景的节奏和所有这些中看到了。但她真的，真的很有趣。你知道，很多时候需要一个伟大的喜剧表演者来表现克制。是的，要有耐心去表现克制。是的，不要试图用自己的梗来塞满场景。
Yeah. And she does it perfectly. Incidentally, she graduated from the University of Missouri's theater program. Good old Missou, that was about 90 minutes away from the school that I went to in Kirksville, Missouri. I had to drive through Missou, Columbia, Missouri to get to Kirksville. You and Brooke, Chris Crosson. Exactly.
是的。她做得非常完美。顺便说一句，她毕业于密苏里大学的戏剧专业。老好的密苏里大学，离我在密苏里州柯克斯维尔上的学校大约90分钟路程。我得开车经过密苏里大学，哥伦比亚，密苏里州才能到柯克斯维尔。你和布鲁克，交错而行。正是如此。
I know. We're both two gals from theater schools in Missouri who landed on the office. Go Mo. The scene between Margaret and Michael is so cringy. Michael literally is like rubbing his forehead. Like he's in pain. He's like, so you get the rent checks every month? And she's like, yeah.
我知道。我们都是来自密苏里州戏剧学校的两个女孩，最终来到了《办公室》。密苏里加油。玛格丽特和迈克尔之间的场景太尴尬了。迈克尔简直是在揉额头。就像他在受苦一样。他说，所以你每个月都收到房租支票？她说，是的。
I mean, it's like. I know. He's like, and then what do you do with them? And she goes, are you really asking me what I do with the checks that people give me? and he's like, I'm just, I'm trying to make conversation, okay? Oh, Michael. And he just talks about, like, he goes, well, this is who I was dating before you. And he shows the photo of Jan.
我是说，这就像。我知道。他说，然后你拿它们做什么？她说，你真的在问我拿人们给我的支票做什么吗？他说，我只是，我只是想找点话题，好吗？哦，迈克尔。他只是谈论，就像，他说，嗯，这是我在你之前约会的人。然后他展示了简的照片。
Oh, and then he calls her by accident. It's just like layer of layer of cringy. And then he kind of starts opening up to Margaret about, like, how it's so hard to find someone. And he tells her, you know, thanks. This has been nice. It's like talking to the old lady on the bus. Mm-hmm. And Margaret's had it.
哦，然后他不小心叫了她的名字。这简直是一层又一层的尴尬。然后他开始向玛格丽特敞开心扉，谈论寻找某人是多么困难。他告诉她，你知道，谢谢。这很不错。就像和公共汽车上的老太太聊天一样。嗯哼。玛格丽特受够了。
She's like, you're rude. That was rude. Well, and then Michael says, well, now you've ruined it. Michael was such a jerk in this scene. Listen, if you had any sympathy for him after dinner party, it evaporated after this scene. Yeah. We were very good at taking you on quite the roller coaster as your feelings for Michael are concerned on this show. But at this scene, I was like, you deserve Jan.
她说，你很粗鲁。那很粗鲁。好吧，然后迈克尔说，好吧，现在你把它搞砸了。迈克尔在这个场景里真是个混蛋。听着，如果你在《晚宴》之后对他还有任何同情心，在这个场景之后就烟消云散了。是的。我们非常擅长带你坐过山车，就你对迈克尔的感受而言。但在这一幕，我想，你活该和简在一起。
You deserve to sleep on the bench at the foot of the bed. You're being such a turd. Exactly. It's very complicated. Well, now we go into the. this wonderful scene where Andy and Kevin are going to meet with the heads of the five families. Yeah. Make their plea.
你活该睡在床尾的长凳上。你真是个混蛋。正是如此。这非常复杂。好吧，现在我们进入了。这个精彩的场景，安迪和凯文要和五个家族的头目见面。是的。提出他们的请求。
They're in what looks like to be some kind of conference room at the Scranton Business Park. I wanted to point out at 14 minutes, 12 seconds, how nice the freaking TV is in this conference room. Yeah. It is a true big flat screen TV, not like Michael's tiny one. Nothing like our crazy old tube TV that. we roll in on a cart for our conference room scenes. Yeah. It's like a fancy big flat screen TV.
他们看起来是在斯克兰顿商业园的某个会议室里。我想指出在14分12秒，这个会议室里的电视有多棒。是的。那是一台真正的大平板电视，不像迈克尔那台小的。一点也不像我们那台疯狂的旧管式电视，我们把它放在推车上推到会议室场景里。是的。就像一台时髦的大平板电视。
Yeah. Imagine if Michael had seen it. He would have passed out. Well, we asked Paul about shooting this scene, and I loved what he had to say. Here it is. So being on set, and sort of be careful what you wish for, because I'm a huge fan of the show, I think they're super funny. And I remember the first time we're about to shoot, they say, okay, quiet on the set.
是的。想象一下如果迈克尔看到了。他会晕过去的。好吧，我们问了保罗关于拍摄这个场景的事，我喜欢他所说的话。在这里。所以身处片场，有点小心你所希望的，因为我是该剧的忠实粉丝，我觉得他们超级有趣。我记得我们第一次要拍摄时，他们说，好了，片场安静。
camera's rolling and I will never forget it but Brian says okay nobody F up Paul and he looks at me and you know he was messing around but it was so funny and then the entire time we shot the scene I had my lines this day but we shot it about 20 30 times and every single time Brian and Ed said different things and I happen to think they're super funny and it was very hard to keep straight face I never knew it was going to come out of their mouths. They were making faces of me, trying to get me to laugh, and I just sit there and be dead serious. I don't want to be the guy to mess up the scene. So working with people who were literally comic geniuses in their delivery and their timing and having to sit there and being
摄像机在转动，我永远不会忘记，但布莱恩说，好了，没人搞砸，保罗。他看着我，你知道他在开玩笑，但这太搞笑了，然后我们拍摄这个场景的整个过程中，我那天有台词，但我们拍了大约20到30次，每次布莱恩和埃德说的都不一样，我碰巧觉得他们超级有趣，要保持严肃太难了。我从来不知道他们嘴里会冒出什么。他们对我做鬼脸，想让我笑，而我只能坐在那里死板着脸。我不想成为搞砸场景的那个人。所以和那些在表达和节奏上简直是喜剧天才的人一起工作，还要坐在那里，成为
the new guy on set and trying to keep a straight face and not to mess up was a challenge, but such a life, a life experience and just so funny to do. And I'm so honored to be a part a small little part of the office. I love that Brian and Ed were trying to mess with them. We would do this. We would know when someone was going to break and we would have a little fun. We would. It's true.
片场的新人，努力保持严肃不搞砸，是一个挑战，但也是一种生活，一种生活体验，做起来太有趣了。我很荣幸能成为《办公室》的一小部分。我喜欢布莱恩和埃德试图捉弄他们。我们会这么做。我们会知道什么时候有人要破功，我们会找点乐子。我们会。这是真的。
Well, Paul mentioned to us, you know, what it was like to get lines at the last minute. But he also talks to us about what it was like just being on the set and the lingo that they used. So we're shooting the scene over and over again. You know, we want to get it right. And sometimes the lines don't work, but the facial expressions are great. So one of the guys comes in and says, when this happens, I forget the word of use. I want you to do this. And then he walked out and I'm looking around like, I have no idea what that means. So the camera guy behind me, he's like, you don't know what that means? I'm like, no, I've never done this before. He goes, okay, I'll tap you on the shoulder when you should say your line. So I was literally sitting there and something was going on and I felt the camera guy who was shooting over my shoulder, tap me on the shoulder when to say my line. And it was just sort of indicative of the whole experience because everybody was so friendly and helpful and just wanted to get it done. right, except I think Brian and Ed, who were just trying to make me laugh the whole time.
好吧，保罗向我们提到了，你知道，最后一刻拿到台词是什么感觉。但他还告诉我们身处片场以及他们使用的行话是什么感觉。所以我们一遍又一遍地拍摄这个场景。你知道，我们想把它拍对。有时台词不起作用，但面部表情很棒。所以其中一个人走进来，说，当这种情况发生时，我忘了用的词。我要你这样做。然后他走开了，我环顾四周，心想，我根本不知道那是什么意思。所以身后的摄像师说，你不知道那是什么意思？我说，不，我以前从没做过这个。他说，好吧，当你该说台词时，我会拍拍你的肩膀。所以我真的坐在那里，发生了一些事情，我感觉到在我身后拍摄的摄像师拍了拍我的肩膀，让我说台词。这简直是整个体验的缩影，因为每个人都非常友好和乐于助人，只想把它做好。对，除了我觉得布莱恩和埃德，他们一直在试图让我笑。
Can I say, Angela, that when we got these audio clips from Paul, the thing that was so fun for me was his observations as a non-actor being on a set, because it really took me back to all of those moments in my career as an actor where you just are learning on the fly. I didn't learn any of this stuff in theater school. And I don't even know if there is any other way to learn it. You just kind of absorb it in the moment. But he sent in an audio clip that is my favorite. Me too. Because I struggled with this too. You and I have talked about this, but I don't think we've ever talked about it on the pod. So this is great. I love that he had the same, the same observation. Okay, we'll play it and then we'll talk about it.
安吉拉，我能说吗，当我们从保罗那里得到这些音频片段时，对我来说最有趣的是他作为一个非演员在片场的观察，因为它真的把我带回了我职业生涯中作为演员的所有那些时刻，你只是在边学边做。我在戏剧学校没学过这些东西。我甚至不知道还有没有其他学习方法。你只是在当下吸收它。但他发来的一段音频是我最喜欢的。我也是。因为我也为此挣扎过。你和我谈过这个，但我觉得我们从来没在播客上谈过。所以这太棒了。我喜欢他有同样的，同样的观察。好的，我们播放它，然后我们讨论它。
So this was a new experience for me. I kind of was my first time being really on the set. And I'm sitting in my trailer going, what do I do now? So I decided to get something to eat. I walk out and I'm like, where can I get some food? And they pointed me in the direction of where the breakfast was. And as I started walking, I heard someone at a headset go, cool guy Paul's going to breakfast. And then I come back and I get them go, cool guy Paul's back in his trailer. And where I went, someone's like, cool guy Paul's in the bathroom, cool guy Paul's in it. Like someone had to know where I was at all time. I thought it was really funny. They had to track me to make sure they knew where I was in case they needed me. So that was one super funny story from being
所以这对我是个全新的体验。这算是我第一次真正出现在片场。我坐在拖车里心想，我现在该做什么？所以我决定去吃点东西。我走出来，心想，我在哪能弄点吃的？他们指给我早餐的方向。当我开始走的时候，我听到有人对着耳机说，酷哥保罗要去吃早餐了。然后我回来，我听到他们说，酷哥保罗回到他的拖车了。我去哪，有人就说，酷哥保罗在洗手间，酷哥保罗在里面。就像有人必须时刻知道我在哪。我觉得这太搞笑了。他们必须追踪我，以确保他们知道我在哪，以防他们需要我。所以这是在片场发生的一个超级有趣的故事。
on the set. Yeah, you guys, on film and television sets, there is a whole network of production assistants that wear these walkie-talkies and they have little earpieces, kind of like the secret service, you know, but not as fancy, but not as fancy. Like when they talk into them, you hear it echo. Well, their job is literally to keep track of all the actors at all times. and you can hear them tracking you all day as you walk by. As you walk by, and sometimes you hear it from the person directly behind you who's actually speaking about you, and then you hear it in stereo from the other person they're talking to as you walk past them. And I guess the theory behind it, Jenna, is that production needs to know where we are
是的，伙计们，在电影和电视片场，有一整套制作助理网络，他们戴着这些对讲机，他们有小耳机，有点像特勤局，你知道，但没那么高级，但没那么高级。就像当他们对着它们说话时，你会听到回声。好吧，他们的工作确实是时刻追踪所有演员。你可以整天听到他们追踪你，当你走过时。当你走过时，有时你会从你身后真正谈论你的人那里听到，然后当你走过他们时，你会从他们正在交谈的另一个人那里听到立体声。我想这背后的理论，珍娜，是制作组需要知道我们在哪
because if the scene is lit and ready, they need us on that soundstage ready to go, and they can't have an actor unaccounted for because then that holds everyone up and it costs money, right? Yeah. So when they're lighting a scene, they let you go back to your trailer. You might use the restroom. You might get a snack. In our case, maybe we pop over to the writer's building and we're hanging out. But once the scene is ready, they have no time to lose because a production day is very regimented. And if you run out of time, that means you probably have to cut something. And you don't want that, right? You don't want to have to cut content. Right. So yeah, all day long. But my favorite thing, Angela, is that they came up with a code for the bathroom. I guess maybe it's to be, I don't know, more discreet, but everyone knows what the code is. The code is 10-1. Jenna is 10-1.
因为如果场景布置好了，准备好了，他们需要我们在那个摄影棚准备好出发，他们不能让演员下落不明，因为那会耽误所有人，而且要花钱，对吧？是的。所以当他们布置场景时，他们让你回拖车。你可能会去洗手间。你可能会吃点零食。在我们的例子中，也许我们跑去编剧大楼闲逛。但一旦场景准备好了，他们就一刻也不能浪费，因为制作日是非常严格的。如果你时间不够，那意味着你可能得剪掉一些东西。你不想那样，对吧？你不想不得不剪掉内容。对。所以是的，整天都在。但我最喜欢的事情，安吉拉，是他们为洗手间想出了一个代码。我想也许是为了，我不知道，更谨慎，但每个人都知道代码是什么。代码是10-1。珍娜是10-1。
Everyone knows when you go to the bathroom on a set. Every single person, it goes through every walkie-talkie. Angela 10-1, Jenna 10-1. And I just want you to know, what if you need to tend to? and you're going to be in there for a minute. Every time they would announce, Jenna is 10-1, I would get a lot of anxiety
每个人都知道你什么时候去片场的洗手间。每一个人，它通过每一个对讲机。安吉拉10-1，珍娜10-1。我只是想让你知道，如果你需要去，而且你要在里面待一会儿。每次他们宣布，珍娜是10-1，我就会感到很焦虑
because I would think I better make it fast or they're going to think I'm doing a poop. Right. What about when we both started pumping? And then you would hear in the Waukei, Angela's pumping. Angel's going to pump? Yeah.
因为我会想我最好快点，否则他们会以为我在拉屎。对。当我们俩开始吸奶时呢？然后你会听到对讲机里说，安吉拉在吸奶。安吉拉要去吸奶？是的。
All your business. All your business through a walkie-talkie. It's crazy. And I get why they have to do it, but it is very surreal. And so that clip from Paul all really, Jen and I immediately called each other. We're like, oh my gosh.
你的所有私事。你的所有私事都通过对讲机。太疯狂了。我明白他们为什么要这样做，但这非常超现实。所以保罗的那段录音，珍娜和我立刻给对方打了电话。我们说，天哪。
He talked about the thingy with the tracking. The tracking. They should warn you in film school. That you're going to be tracked all day. They should warn you because it's very jarring at first. Yeah. Well, let's just say that this meeting of the five families goes very well. It also goes very quickly in about three sentences.
他谈到了那个追踪的事情。追踪。他们应该在电影学校警告你。你会整天被追踪。他们应该警告你，因为起初这非常刺耳。是的。好吧，我们就说五个家族的这次会议进行得非常顺利。它也进行得非常快，大约三句话。
W.B. Jones agrees, fine, you can have your parking space. back. It's a triumph. Listen, it looks like Kevin's about to cry, and Bill Kress is not here for that. He can't handle a grown man crying about a parking spot. And so Paul Faus calls it. He's like, just give them their spots back. And it just wraps up so quickly. It does. And then Paul has a great line where he says this could have been an email, which is like a meme. It also speaks to me. Yeah. I mean, Paul needs to get out and ride his motorcycle. He's done. Kevin's talking head after this St. Stacey broke my heart. Brian did such a good job with it. He just says that after Stacey broke up with him, it was really a tough time. And, well, it's just nice to win one. And he tears up. It was so sweet.
W.B.琼斯同意了，好吧，你可以拿回你的停车位。这是一个胜利。听着，看起来凯文快要哭了，比尔·克雷斯可受不了这个。他无法忍受一个成年男人因为停车位而哭泣。所以保罗·福斯叫停了。他说，就把车位还给他们吧。然后它很快就结束了。确实。然后保罗有一句很棒的台词，他说这本可以通过电子邮件解决，这就像一个梗。它也触动了我。是的。我是说，保罗需要出去骑他的摩托车了。他完成了。凯文在这次圣斯泰西分手后的谈话头让我心碎。布莱恩做得太好了。他只是说在斯泰西和他分手后，那真是一段艰难的时光。而且，嗯，赢一次真好。他流泪了。太甜了。
Yeah. Guys, we didn't go to the character of Kevin very often for a heartfelt moment on the show. And it's a shame because Brian Baumgartner is a fantastic actor. Yeah. And you can see that. in this talking head. Yeah, I was excited to get to see this performance from him. Great job, B. Oh, no, Michael has come back from his date, and he's very angry. Mm-hmm. He gives a big speech.
是的。伙计们，我们没有经常在剧中为凯文这个角色安排感人的时刻。这很遗憾，因为布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳是一位出色的演员。是的。你可以看到这一点。在这个谈话头里。是的，我很高兴能看到他这次表演。干得好，B。哦，不，迈克尔从约会中回来了，他非常生气。嗯哼。他发表了一大段演讲。
Angela, here are the things that he's a man of. Intensity, cool, youth, and passionately. He's a man of passionately. He's a man of youth and passionately. Well, at 15 minutes, minutes, 10 seconds, you might notice I'm writing on the top of my desk. I have several papers on this very little thin lip of the top of my desk. I had to do that for camera because when I was staging my writing on the actual desk, they couldn't see my face when Michael entered.
安吉拉，这是他所代表的东西。强度、酷、青春和激情。他是一个充满激情的人。他是一个青春和充满激情的人。好吧，在15分10秒，你可能会注意到我在桌子顶上写字。我在桌子顶上那个非常薄的边缘上有几张纸。我必须为摄像机这样做，因为当我把我的写作安排在实际桌子上时，迈克尔进来时他们看不到我的脸。
I have to imagine that was a tough reach and very awkward because you're leaning over your desk to write on a tiny ledge. Well, I'll tell you something. Pam's desk was very narrow in general. I couldn't fit more than a keyboard on it. In order to write on Pam's actual desk, which was made very thin, I think, for production. It was always awkward. Always. Yeah. So I've perched up on that little ledge, which was also awkward. In this scene, Jenna, it seems like Jim and Pam are just kind of teasing each other. Like, he's like, what were you thinking, setting Michael up with your landlord? Now you have to move out. That went horribly. And they're kind of joking.
我不得不想象那是一个艰难的触及，非常尴尬，因为你弯腰在桌子上写在一个小小的边缘上。好吧，我告诉你一件事。帕姆的桌子总体上非常窄。我甚至放不下键盘。为了在帕姆实际的桌子上写字，我想那是为了制作而做得非常薄。它总是很尴尬。总是。是的。所以我栖息在那个小边缘上，那也很尴尬。在这个场景里，珍娜，看起来吉姆和帕姆只是在互相调侃。就像，他说，你在想什么，把迈克尔介绍给你的房东？现在你得搬出去了。那太糟糕了。他们是在开玩笑。
And she's like, maybe I should move in with my boyfriend. And then Pam has a moment of vulnerability. And you see it in your face, Jenna, where you're going to be an advocate for yourself. This is something you've been working on. And she says, you know what? I'm only going to move in with my boyfriend if I'm engaged. Yeah. And Jim doesn't miss a beat.
她说，也许我应该和我的男朋友住在一起。然后帕姆有了一个脆弱的时刻。你在你的脸上看到了，珍娜，你要成为你自己的拥护者。这是你一直在努力的事情。她说，你知道吗？我只有在订婚后才会和我的男朋友住在一起。是的。吉姆没有错过任何一个节拍。
He's like, oh, it's coming. Of course. And then Pam just kind of keeps joking along. And Jenna, I was like, does Pam? I mean, In the moment, I was positive that Jim was serious. Does Pam know? Does Pam know he's doing a bit?
他说，哦，快了。当然。然后帕姆只是继续开玩笑。珍娜，我当时想，帕姆吗？我是说，在那一刻，我肯定吉姆是认真的。帕姆知道吗？帕姆知道他在演戏吗？
Does it hit her that he's not? I think this maybe in my backstory was kind of one of the first times that this idea of them getting engaged or married has really come up. And that was a reason why I chose to kind of hesitate as well when Pam says, oh, I'm not going to move in with anyone until, I'm engaged is because this idea of being engaged, it's not something that I thought they had talked about a lot yet. No, and that's how it reads. As an audience, I loved it because this is how real life stuff comes up. Sometimes it just seeps in to like a mundane conversation.
她意识到他不是吗？我想这也许在我的背景故事中是他们订婚或结婚这个想法第一次真正出现。这也是为什么当帕姆说，哦，我不会和任何人住在一起直到，我订婚时，我也选择犹豫的原因，因为这个订婚的想法，这不是我认为他们已经谈论过很多的事情。不，读起来就是这样。作为观众，我喜欢它，因为这就是现实生活中的事情出现的方式。有时它只是渗入到像平凡的对话中。
And then you're like, oh, crap, we're here now. Okay. Yes. And so I think Pam isn't totally sure what to do with this conversation. Was it a bit? Is he being serious? Now, he has a talking head for the audience where he says, oh, I'm not kidding. I got this a week after we started dating.
然后你会想，哦，该死，我们现在到这儿了。好的。是的。所以我认为帕姆并不完全确定该如何处理这段对话。这是一个梗吗？他是认真的吗？现在，他有一个给观众的谈话头，他说，哦，我没开玩笑。我在我们开始约会一周后就有了这个。
And he shows an engagement ring. And I'm sorry, does he carry it to work with him every day? I don't know. Does it live in his pocket? Is he too worried to leave it at his apartment? Like, he has it ready to go. We had a fan question from Abigail B who said, is the ring Jim shows the camera, the ring he proposes with later and the one that Pam wears
他展示了一枚订婚戒指。我很抱歉，他每天都带着它去上班吗？我不知道。它住在他的口袋里吗？他太担心把它留在公寓里了吗？就像，他准备好了。我们收到了来自阿比盖尔·B的粉丝提问，她说，吉姆展示给摄像机的戒指，是他后来求婚时用的戒指，也是帕姆戴的那枚吗？
for the rest of the show. I think it is. I think that it is. I remember Phil Shea coming up to me and presenting me with a tray of rings and he and I had a very long conversation about what kind of ring would Jim buy Pam? Like, Jim's going to hit it out of the park for Pam. Remember, Pam was always a little disappointed in her ring from Roy. That was my backstory. The cluster. Yes. And so Phil was like, what would make Pam's heart sing? And I remember picking that ring. So yeah, I think it is that ring. Pretty bold move, Jim. To buy it the first week you guys started dating. Yeah. But I guess he knew he loved her for a long time. Yeah. Well, guys, here's the scene that's in Michael's office that I love. It's shot a little different. this was Jeff Blitz.
在节目的剩余部分。我想是的。我想是的。我记得菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）走到我面前，递给我一个装满戒指的托盘，我和他进行了一次非常长的谈话，讨论吉姆会给帕姆买什么样的戒指？吉姆肯定会给帕姆一个大惊喜。记得吗，帕姆一直对她从罗伊那里得到的戒指有点失望。那是我的背景故事。那个簇状的。是的。所以菲尔问，什么能让帕姆心动？我记得选了那枚戒指。所以是的，我想就是那枚戒指。吉姆，真是大胆的举动。在你们开始约会的第一个星期就买了它。是的。但我猜他早就知道他爱她很久了。是的。好吧，伙计们，这是迈克尔办公室里我最喜欢的一幕。拍摄手法有点不同。这是杰夫·布里茨（Jeff Blitz）拍的。
You know, there's always so many of the same scenes in the same places because we only had one set. And every once in a while a director would find a fun way to shoot. And Jeff Blitz had this idea for this scene between Michael and Dwight, that he would just lower the camera a little and shoot at an angle and slowly push in as Dwight convinces Michael that what he needs is closure. And when I watched the scene, there was a brief moment that I thought he meant with Jan. Same. He needs closure with Jan. But no. No.
你知道，同样的地方总是有很多相同的场景，因为我们只有一个布景。偶尔会有导演想出有趣的拍摄方式。杰夫·布里茨对迈克尔和德怀特之间的这一幕有个想法，他会把摄像机稍微降低，以一个角度拍摄，并缓慢推进，同时德怀特说服迈克尔他需要的是了结。当我看到这一幕时，有一瞬间我以为他指的是简。我也是。他需要和简做个了结。但不是。不是。
It's with the chair model. So they head to the cemetery of a woman he's never met. Mm-hmm. That's right. And they are going to launch into a tribute to her by singing a version of American Pie. Bye. by Miss Chair Model Lady. Oh my gosh.
是关于那个椅子模特。所以他们去了他从未谋面的女人的墓地。嗯哼。没错。他们要通过唱一首《美国派》（American Pie）的版本来向她致敬。再见，椅子模特小姐。天哪。
So, you know, the writers actually had a hard time getting a song cleared for this. Shocker. The first song they were going to parody was Elton John's Candle in the Wind, but they could not get the rights because here's an interesting bit of trivia. He had given permission for the song to be parodied on 30 Rock and he did not care for the results. So he said no more parodies of Candle in the Wind. No. Okay.
所以，你知道，编剧们在为这一集获得歌曲授权时确实遇到了困难。真让人吃惊。他们最初打算恶搞的歌曲是埃尔顿·约翰（Elton John）的《风中之烛》（Candle in the Wind），但他们无法获得版权，因为这里有一个有趣的冷知识。他曾允许这首歌在《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）中被恶搞，但他不喜欢结果。所以他说不再允许恶搞《风中之烛》。不。好吧。
They also wrote parodies of Legs by ZZ Top. She's got legs. How is that a song you sing at a gravesite? She was a chair model and you really see her legs in the picture. Oh, my gosh. Okay. And then also Ruby Tuesday by the Rolling Stones. Oh, I love Ruby Tuesday.
他们还写了ZZ Top乐队《腿》（Legs）的恶搞版。她有双腿。那怎么能是在墓地唱的歌呢？她是个椅子模特，你在照片里确实能看到她的腿。天哪。好吧。还有滚石乐队（The Rolling Stones）的《鲁比·图斯黛》（Ruby Tuesday）。哦，我喜欢《鲁比·图斯黛》。
But the song that got cleared was American Pie. And I'm so glad it did because I really love them in the dark singing. Well, we can't wrap up this episode without this adorable scene. Jenna, I literally wrote adorable and highlighted it. Mm-hmm. Between Jim and Pam as they're walking to the satellite parking lot. And the sun is setting. You guys both look like angels.
但最终获得授权的歌曲是《美国派》。我很高兴它获得了授权，因为我真的很喜欢他们在黑暗中唱歌的样子。好吧，我们不能在没有这个可爱场景的情况下结束这一集。珍娜，我真的写了“可爱”并把它高亮了。嗯哼。在吉姆和帕姆走向卫星停车场的时候。太阳正在下山。你们俩看起来都像天使。
You both look so flippin adorable. Well, I remember we had to wait in our trailer for that light. That's called The Magic Hour in the biz. And there's this little 45 minutes, and the sun is truly magical. Everybody, take your photos at Magic Hour. It's when you look the best. That's right.
你们俩看起来都太可爱了。好吧，我记得我们不得不在拖车里等待那种光线。在业内这被称为“魔幻时刻”。只有这短短的45分钟，太阳确实很神奇。大家，在魔幻时刻拍照吧。那是你看起来最美的时候。没错。
If you're planning a wedding, plan for some like Magic Hour photos. Yeah. So we waited for that moment and we could only do a few takes because then we were going to lose the light. He drops to one knee. Mm-hmm. Well, I'll tell you, this moment was promoed like crazy. Like crazy. I bet they blasted it out.
如果你正在计划婚礼，计划一些像魔幻时刻那样的照片。是的。所以我们等待着那一刻，我们只能拍几次，因为之后光线就会消失。他单膝跪地。嗯哼。好吧，我告诉你，这一刻被疯狂地宣传了。疯狂地。我敢打赌他们大肆宣传了它。
Yeah. Well, you know, we talked about how season four was interrupted by the writer's strike. The writers originally had this very, very big storyline for Jim and Pam that I think involved them moving in together, if I'm correct. And instead, because we lost a bunch of episodes, they were like, you know what? We should skip that and they should just get engaged. Or we should just skip to the part where we're thinking they might get engaged any minute. And so that was where this part of the story came from. I like it. I like that Pam still had her own place.
是的。好吧，你知道，我们谈到了第四季是如何被编剧罢工打断的。编剧们最初为吉姆和帕姆准备了一个非常、非常大的故事情节，如果我没记错的话，涉及他们搬到一起住。相反，因为我们损失了很多集，他们觉得，你知道吗？我们应该跳过那个，他们应该直接订婚。或者我们应该直接跳到我们认为他们随时可能订婚的部分。所以这就是故事这一部分的来源。我喜欢它。我喜欢帕姆仍然有自己的住处。
I like all of that storyline for her because you sort of feel like Pam lived with Roy for a long time. And then she finally carved out her own space in the world. And I really liked that choice. Well, your reaction when you realize that Jim is faking is so great. It's so cute. You're like, I hate you. And he's like, what? It's really cute.
我喜欢她所有的那个故事情节，因为你会觉得帕姆和罗伊住了很长时间。然后她终于在世界上开辟了自己的空间。我真的很喜欢那个选择。好吧，当你意识到吉姆在假装时，你的反应太棒了。太可爱了。你说，我恨你。他说，什么？真的很可爱。
Yeah. I have some bad news. What? I mean, spoiler alert, Pam's going to need to go to art school. We're going to frustrate you. I know. The proposal's going to take a little while, but we're planning the seeds. They have to pull you guys apart to put you back together.
是的。我有个坏消息。什么？我是说，剧透预警，帕姆需要去艺术学校。我们要让你感到沮丧。我知道。求婚还需要一点时间，但我们正在埋下种子。他们必须把你们分开，然后再让你们重聚。
It makes me crazy. I know. Well, guys, that is chair model. Next up is night out. I'm really enjoying season four, Angela, I have to say. Me too. So fun. And for all of you chair models out there, just know your work is not in vain. You might be inspiring others to find true love. And Paul, thank you so much for sitting in these audio clips
这让我发疯。我知道。好吧，伙计们，这就是《椅子模特》。接下来是《外出之夜》。我真的很享受第四季，安吉拉，我必须说。我也是。太有趣了。对于你们所有的椅子模特，要知道你们的工作不是徒劳的。你们可能正在激励他人找到真爱。保罗，非常感谢你坐在这里录制这些音频片段
and being so quick to respond when I texted you. You are just such a delight. And I adore you. And these made our day, Jenna. And you guys, 1-800-prepared.com. Get your preparedness safety and survival information there and all the kits you might ever need. You know I'm on that. Oh, I know. I was like, oh, Paul, there's some good stuff on here. Christmas gift for me, earmark that. Survival and emergency kits and products, Jenna. We'll see you next week, everyone. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer
并且在我给你发短信时回复得如此迅速。你真是太令人愉快了。我崇拜你。这些让我们的这一天变得很棒，珍娜。还有你们，1-800-prepared.com。在那里获取你的准备安全和生存信息以及你可能需要的所有工具包。你知道我正在关注那个。哦，我知道。我当时想，哦，保罗，这里面有好东西。给我的圣诞礼物，标记一下。生存和应急工具包及产品，珍娜。大家下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤尔金斯（Cassie Juerkins），我们的音频工程师和副制片人
is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。